So. Schauen wir mal. Refresh. Refresh. Quality Options. BÄM! Das ist echt, da ist, ich hab's
predicted. Da ist Twitch durchschaubar. Also F5. Endlich das Nass zusammenbauen. Ja, ich
zeige euch vorher nochmal was ich jetzt für Teile habe. Ich hab übelst Trick 17. Ey Leute,
ich sag's euch. Also. Das da schnell wird. Trick, das ist ja nicht mal Trick 17, das ist Trick 34
oder sowas. Mindestens. Mindestens Trick 37. 34. Ist auch vollkommen egal. Du, du, du, du, du, du.
Wie fangen wir denn jetzt am besten an? Wie fangen wir denn jetzt am besten an? Ähm. Wie fangen
wir am besten an? Ich mach erstmal meine VM an. Die brauchen wir auf jeden Fall zum Testen,
wie schnell das Ganze ist. Achja, genau, der Boss ist back. Woran lag's denn jetzt mit deiner
Grafikkader? Achso, du hast ja schon geschrieben, es lag am Netzteil. Und zwar reichte die Wattzahl
und so weiter aus, aber die Qualitätszahlen haben ein Problem mit der Mega64. Das kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen, dass ein Netzteil ein Problem mit einer Grafikkader hat. Das kann ich mir
echt nicht vorstellen. Ups. Dem Netzteil ist doch vollkommen egal was da dran hängt. So weit die
Theorie zumindest, ne? Warum hast du keine Benachrichtigung bekommen, dass ich streme? Ja,
vielleicht will Twitch nicht, dass du guckst. Weil heute die krassen Hacks verraten werden.
Die krassen, die krassen Hardware Hacks. Ein Dance Game Sub. Bester. Bester. Bester Mann.
Ich mein, es kann schon sein, dass vielleicht ein bisschen zu wenig Strom, aber das kann,
nein, eigentlich kann das nicht sein. Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Aber gut, wenn du es
ausprobiert hast, ich mein, es ist nicht so, dass ich sag, du erzählst Blödsinn, es ist deine
Grafikkader. Ich glaub dir das. Aber, ähm, ich find's schon auf jeden Fall merkwürdig. Das
ganze Netzteilproblem ist, hätt ich nicht dran gedacht. Oh, der Patroni ist auch am Start.
Chillen. Chillstappen jetzt. Weiß noch, wie ich vor irgendwie zwei Jahren hab ich übelst
geflamet, wie scheiße Chillstapp ist. Und auch wenn ich kein großer Elektronikmusik-Fan bin,
irgendwie ist das doch sehr entspannend. Also, es ist halt gechillt. Kann nicht schlecht ins
Ohr schreien, um gechillt zu sein. Okay, wie fangen wir denn jetzt am besten an? Ich muss
jetzt erstmal kurz überlegen. Also, ich zeig euch jetzt erstmal vielleicht am besten, was
ich jetzt für Hardware drinne hab, oder? Also, was ich für Hardware bestellt hab. Also, wir
haben, wir haben, wir machen mal hier mal, also, als Hardware haben wir folgendes. Ah,
okay, hier haben wir noch das Bild offen vom letzten Mal. Also, es ist nicht mehr ganz so,
wie das hier steht. Es ist dieses, wobei, doch, das ist gar nicht mal so verkehrt, was hier
steht. Ich find das immer geil, wenn die Musik sich nicht entscheiden kann, wie laut sie
ist. So, jetzt aber. Ähm, also, was haben wir denn jetzt, was hab ich denn jetzt drinne?
Also, fangen wir mal oben an. Netzteil ist immer noch das gleiche, das hatte ich auch
noch am Start. Warum soll ich das neu machen? Machst du hier raus auch ein YouTube-Video?
Das mach ich erst, wenn das Ding ein bisschen gelaufen ist. Weil ich denke, das ist ein
richtig cooles Bild, was man auch nachbauen kann. Also, ich, ich, ich, ich hab's irgendwie
so im Gefühl, dass das wirklich was ist, was viele Leute gebrauchen können. Also, ähm,
das Board stimmt noch. Ich mach mal die Preise weg. Das können wir uns nachher zusammenrechnen.
Es ist 20, 30 Euro teurer, wie das, was ich hier eingeschrieben hab. Also, wir haben,
wir haben das Netzteil, haben wir das hier, als Board haben wir das hier, als Case hab
ich das bestellt. Das Problem ist nur, das sind die PCI-Slots zu kurz hinten. Guck mal,
ich zeig's euch. Das hat man aber auf dem, das hat man auf dem Bild nicht so richtig
gesehen. Ähm, warum denkt ihr, dass das eine Adresse ist? Hat man auf dem Bild nicht so
richtig gesehen. Ich, ich würd mir normalerweise auch keine andere Gehäuse kaufen. Das Problem
ist, in Deutschland ist die Auswahl ein bisschen beschränkt. Ähm, das Ding sieht übrigens
genauso aus wie auf dem Bild. Das ist eigentlich ganz gut verarbeitet. Das Problem ist nur,
man hätte sich das hier mal genauer angucken müssen, dass die PCI-Steckplätze hier sind.
Und, da passt natürlich nix gescheites dahinter, ne? Da, wenn du da ne Karte dazwischen brachst,
das kann, das kann, das muss, das ist nicht nur Low Profile, das ist Hyper Profile oder
so. Also, in beide Richtungen. Hyper Profile, dass es überhaupt da reinpasst. Und, das
passt nicht. Ja, von der Tiefe, genau. Also, das hat noch nichts mit Low Profile, das ist
ein volles, volle, volle PCI-Slot, aber da hinten ist zu wenig Platz. Ich hab jetzt
schon geguckt, ob man das nicht irgendwie tauschen kann, also sprich, ähm, die Plände
irgendwie rumdrehen, dass man, dass man, ähm, das dahin macht, weil die PCI-Slots kriegt
man da nicht hin, oder vielleicht doch irgendwie. Es sind ein paar Schrauben drin, aber es
sieht nicht so gut aus. Nichtsdestotrotz, ich hab jetzt noch was viel Besseres gefunden,
und zwar, ähm, Moin, X, Azerbaijan, ähm, die haben noch ein anderes ganz gutes Gehäuse,
das sich, äh, gut eignet für, für unser Bild, und zwar, äh, nein, wo ist das? Storage-Gehäuse,
Storage-Gehäuse, das da, das da. Das werd ich mir ordern, das hab ich auch nicht, wozu?
Ich mein, das Ding läuft auch ohne Gehäuse. Das Ding ist ganz cool, weil, das hat, und
deswegen sag ich, das ist wirklich so ein universelles, wirklich sehr nicees Bild, ähm, also, Bild
von, von Bauen, ne, und zwar, das Gehäuse unterstützt, äh, hat einen Hotspot-Rahmen
für vier, für vier Einschübe. Ich mein, ich, das Ding kostet irgendwie 70 Euro, und
das ist für ein Gehäuse mit einem vierfacher Hotspot-Rahmen jetzt nicht unbedingt die
Welt, es ist sogar relativ billig, also keine Ahnung, was das für eine Qualität hat, das
ist aber eh nicht das Super Enterprise-Nas, das muss einem jedem, das muss ja im Endeffekt
jedem klar sein, ja? Mit einem Dual-Core oder mit einem Quad-Core, äh, Zeleron kommst du
jetzt nicht so super weit, aber für daheim und für, keine Ahnung, die Familie als Benutzer
reicht das voll und ganz aus. Wie kann das so 70 Euro kosten? Ich hab keine Ahnung, ordentlicher
Wechselrahmen kostet normalerweise schon mehr. Ich hab keine Ahnung, warum das so billig
ist, aber ich mein, ich will mich letztendlich nicht beschweren, ne? Ja, ich will, ich will
mich nicht beschweren, dass das Gehäuse so billig ist, sonst wird's noch teurer. So,
also wir nehmen jetzt, wir nehmen jetzt das Gehäuse hier, ähm, so, Netzwerk hab ich eingekauft
auf, ähm, ich hab einmal 10G-Netzwerkkarten bestellt auf Ebay und einmal, ähm, auf Amazon
und zwar hab ich bestellt die, ähm, das ist aber auch was, das, das veranschlag ich
mal hier so als, ähm, 20, 30, 40 Euro im Bild, das kann man nicht, das kann man nicht
neu kaufen. Man kann alles andere, kann man neu kaufen in Deutschland, überhaupt kein
Problem über Amazon, aber die, äh, die 10G-Netzwerkkarten, die kann man sich nicht neu kaufen, weil das
ist viel, viel zu teuer. Und ich hab mir so ein Kit gekauft, ein Kit mit zwei Netzwerkkarten
und, äh, Kupfer Direct-Attached-Kabel und ich hab mir noch gekauft einen Pack davon,
da muss man aber mal gucken, ich hab sie für irgendwie 40 Euro oder so was gekriegt, da
muss man auch mal Ebay ein bisschen, äh, Scavenger einschalten, ähm, weil wenn man
sich anguckt, was da, was da, guck hier, das gibt's teilweise viel, viel billiger, ähm,
wenn man sich nämlich anguckt, was, ähm, 10G-Karten, 10G-SFP-Plus-Karten neu kosten,
dann bezahlt es, keine Ahnung, 400 Euro, das ist halt beknackt, ja. Ihr könnt auch, das
könnt ihr euch theoretisch überall kaufen, vollkommen egal. Also sprich, wir können
mal danach suchen jetzt, Reiherport, guck, hier ist sogar noch ein bisschen teurer, hier
ist noch ein bisschen billiger, also das ist wirklich ziemlich, ähm, hier gibt's das
auf Ebay, das ist ziemlich random, ich hab letztens einen Post gesehen auf Reddit, hat's
einer für irgendwie 25 Dollar oder so auf Ebay gekriegt. Äh, ich bau ein NAS, ich
bau ein NAS, allerdings ein, ich hab, ähm, relativ, also ich hab ziemlich hohe Ziele
gesteckt für das NAS, und zwar, ähm, da müssen wir mal gucken, wie weit wir da reinkommen,
also erstens, es soll billig sein, 250 bis 300 Euro, ja, Infinite, äh, Infinite, Infinite,
Infinity, ich kann mir das immer nicht merken, wie das genau heißt, ähm, da hast du aber
andere Probleme mit, ich glaub, Infini-, Infin-, ich kann mit, wie gesagt, ich kann's nicht
merken, Infini-Band, ja, das, ich glaub, das stimmt sogar, also, ich hab ja da relativ
hohe Ansprüche gestellt, ich wollte quasi wirklich, erstens wollte ich einen 10G-NAS
bauen, und das Wichtigste ist, dass soll günstig sein, günstig bedeutet 250 bis 300 Euro,
irgendwie in dem Dreh, weil, ähm, ich mein, man kann sich auch für 1000 Euro ein fertiges
10G-NAS kaufen, kein Ding, da sind aber wie gesagt bei beiden noch keine Platten dabei,
dann soll das, wie gesagt, ein 10G-NAS sein, halbwegs geschwind, ähm, es soll leise sein,
also ich will da kein, ähm, mir kein irgendwie HP-Server ins Rack stellen, der dann den Hubschrauber
macht, und es soll wenig Strom verbrauchen, also sprich eigentlich alle so Dinge, die
sich nie so richtig miteinander vertragen, auch so alles so komplett, ähm, und, und
das ist jetzt, was ich, was ich noch abgecreated hab, und man sollte so viel wie möglich an
Platten reinkriegen, so viel wie möglich heißt, was man irgendwie mit den Boards und
den Sachen, die man sich ausgesucht hat, machen kann, äh, InfiniBand nutzt kein TCP-IP-Line,
das ist irgendwie so ein, so ein Cluster-Interconnect-Gedöns, hab ich aber nix mitgemacht, genau,
und ich bin jetzt zu dem Schluss gekommen, wenn das so klappt, wie ich mir das vorgestellt
hab, dann kriegen wir, also das ist das NAS-Bild, und zwar ist das das, also wir haben, wir
haben quasi Budget, also sagen wir irgendwie, äh, so, sagen wir mal um die 300€, so irgendwie
in dem Dreh, ja, sagen wir so 250 bis 300€, irgendwie, ähm, wir wollen, wir, äh, kann
man das nicht irgendwie ein bisschen kleiner machen, also irgendwie 200, 300€, wir wollen
Performance-CNG haben, also halbwegs, ich kann euch gleich schon verraten, wir werden
keine 10G schaffen, wenn wir 5GB plus packen, bin ich eigentlich zufrieden, weil da hat
man richtig was schon, denn, äh, alles dazu kommt nämlich, dass es eh schwierig wird,
mit dem, was du mit 2 bis 4 Platten reinstecken kannst, dass du quasi 10G wirste, da musstest
du, musstest, musstest, musstest schon einen SSD-Raid oder irgendwie sowas machen, ja,
also, ich sag mal, wenn wir auf, ähm, ja, wenn wir, wenn wir auf, sagen wir mal, wenn
wir auf 5G plus kommen, das ist so das Ziel ungefähr, und das habe ich so mal überschlagen,
das sollte auch ungefähr hinkommen, das werden wir dann gleich mal ausprobieren mit IP-Perf
oder sowas, gucken wir mal, einfach mal was drüber geht, falls der überhaupt, falls
der überhaupt die Netzwerkkarte erkennt, da kommen wir jetzt nochmal, ich erzähle euch
jetzt auch gleich, wo das Trick reich ist und wo das Problem an dem Bild ist, ähm,
es soll silent sein, silent bedeutet, dass da keine Lüfter drinne rumwurscht, denn außer
die Platten, die sich drehen, da kann ich leider nichts dran ändern, wenn sich die Platten
nicht drehen, haben wir halt andere Probleme, und es soll, äh, stromsparend sein, so, und
jetzt zeige ich euch mal was, was, ähm, also, übelstes Trick 17, und ich hoffe, es klappt,
ich hoffe wirklich, es klappt, wenn es nicht klappt, dann kann man das Bild komplett in
die Tonne klappen, weil, dann kriegen wir keine 10G raus, bzw. auch keine 5G, dann kriegen
wir, was weiß ich, 2G, 3G oder so raus, das ist dann nicht so schön auf jeden Fall, und
wir kriegen keine Platten, und wir kriegen keine zusätzlichen Platten dran, ähm, genau,
das ist das Ziel dabei, wie gesagt, Netzteil, habe ich hier dieses, dieses, äh, 60W Pico
PSU Trink, das hatte ich noch, so, und dieses Mainboard, die habe ich nämlich massiv gebaited,
dieses Mainboard, wenn man sich das hier nämlich anguckt auf dem Bild, denkt man sich so, oh,
das ist ja nice, wir haben ein X16, PCI Express X16 Anschluss, und, ähm, da habe ich auch
gedacht, oh, das ist ultra nice, steht ja auch hier überall da, was ich nicht gesehen habe
ist, und wo ich, äh, hardcore gebaited wurde, ähm, ist das hier, da steht hier, irgendwo
steht das drinnen, da hätte ich aber eigentlich selbst drauf kommen können, weil, wie sollen
sie überhaupt 16-fach anbinden, ein 16er, Patrick, aber genau gucken, das ist ein 16er,
das ist kein 8er, oder, ne, 16er, steht doch sogar da, so, und das hier, das hier ist
der Knackpunkt, das ist gebaited, ich mein, die haben, die haben ja nicht beschissen, es
steht da, und außerdem hätte man auch davon ausgehen können, man hätte auch davon ausgehen
können, dass die auf dieser Plattform gar kein PCI Express 16-Slot irgendwie anbinden
können, da hätte man von ausgehen können, weil die Plattform bietet an sich gar nicht
so viele PCI Express Lanes, das geht gar nicht, so, und dann hat er noch einen Sockel für
Wireless und sowas, und einen M2 Sockel für eine SSD, und jetzt kommt Trick 17, das ist
übelst nice, und ich glaube, ich hoffe echt, dass das funktioniert, wenn das funktioniert,
gibt's das, Poggers Hyper Poggers, Hyper Pogu, gibt's das, hat das schon einer gemacht
als E-Mode, Hyper Pogu, ist das, Pogu Ideas for Company Names, Face Pogu, Hyper Pogu,
Style Pogu, offensiv, ey, äh, STS, PCI Express über SATA, ja, ungefähr, ungefähr, so,
was man nämlich wissen muss, ist, was man nämlich wissen muss, ist, dass, ähm, und
das ist wirklich Massive Trick 17, was man wissen muss, ist, das ist ein M2 Slot, also
sprich ein M2 Key M, oder M-Key heißt es, glaube ich, also sprich sowas hier, ne, das
heißt umgedreht, ne, das heißt M-Key, so, und das da, so ein Ding ist das, so ein Slot
hier, den habt ihr vielleicht auch auf dem Mainboard, die meisten, die meisten, ähm,
nein, wir machen PCI Express über WLAN, was, was denn sonst, ähm, so, und was man wissen
muss, dass diese, diese M2 intern, eigentlich, also diese, diese M2 M-Key, wenn der, wenn
der Mainboard Hersteller nicht, ähm, der Patrick hat's schon erkannt, wenn der Mainboard Hersteller
nicht rumtrickst, dann ist das im Endeffekt quasi, ähm, diese M2 Slot, haben wir, haben
wir jetzt, das ist kein schönes Bild von unserem M2 Slot, genau, dann ist der M2 Slot intern
eigentlich im Prinzip sowas wie ein PCI Express X2 Slot, da kannst du auch anderes Zeug drüber
machen, da musst du keine SSD reinmachen, kannst du SSD reinmachen, du kannst allerdings
auch, ähm, ähm, du kannst allerdings auch teilweise USB dran machen, und alles mögliche,
ja, und die Sache ist die, ich hab das schon vor einer Weile mal für meine fette 4HE-Kiste
gemacht, wenn der Mainboard Hersteller das unterstützt, ähm, dann funktioniert das,
deswegen hab ich mir einen Adapter gekauft, ähm, und zwar einen M2 zu PCI Express Adapter,
so ein Ding hatte ich, ich hab das schon mal ausprobiert, also ich weiß von der anderen
Kiste, dass das funktioniert, wenn der Mainboard Hersteller das richtig macht, ähm, und zwar,
wenn mich das Mainboard debattet, hab ich gelitten, ja, also wenn die da irgendwelche PCI Express
Tricks machen, oder nicht richtig angebunden haben, oder was auch immer machen, dann hab
ich gelitten, so, und zwar hab ich mir diesen, nein, äh, diesen Adapter, ungefähr diesen
Adapter gekauft, es find, find ich den Adapter jetzt nicht, aber das sieht ungefähr so aus,
das ist ein M2 Key mit, ich bin jetzt bescheuert, wo ist es denn, den da, das ist nämlich ein
M2 Key mit PCI Express Vierfachslot obendrauf, das ist, äh, aber das geht, ja Patrick jetzt
warte es doch mal ab, das kriegen wir gleich raus, was es ist, ob es überhaupt funktioniert,
es ist auf jeden Fall schneller als einfach über den PCI Express Slot, huge, ja, so,
und das Ding hab ich mir noch mal bestellt, wie gesagt, ich hab hier in der anderen Kiste
ja auch schon sowas in der Richtung drinne, deswegen weiß ich, dass es funktioniert, weil
als Privatperson ist das Setup eigentlich OP, nö, als Privatperson ist das Setup auch
gut, ähm, so, also da ist dann im Endeffekt noch so Stromdings dabei, dass man, falls man
Karte hat, die ein bisschen mehr braucht, so, zumindest hat man jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten,
also ich stöpsel dann das Ding hier rein und, äh, in M2 Slot und da mach ich die Karte
rein, man hat das Problem, wenn man sich so eine hier kauft, die ich, also die, wenn
man sich so eine kauft, hier zum Beispiel über Ebay oder so, dann passt das, das ist
ein ganz normaler Vierfach Anschluss, wenn man sich die etwas günstige Variante kauft,
nämlich die Zweier, gebraucht natürlich für 30, macht im Prinzip von der Geschwindigkeit
kein großer Unterschied, die neuere braucht glaube ich ein bisschen weniger Strom und
sowas, aber, es macht nicht viel Unterschied, ja, Simbaro, wir gucken gleich, so, und, ähm,
die Alte hast du das Problem, das ist eine Achtfachkarte, dann darfst du Linux-Techtab-Style
deinen PCI-Expressplatz aufdrehmeln, aber das, äh, machen wir nicht, deswegen habe
ich eine Karte gekauft, die vierfach ist und reinpasst, ohne aufzuschnibbeln den PCI-Expressplatz,
äh, Slot, so, ok, also das Case holen wir, das Mainboard haben wir, und dann ist noch
der, der, der, Moment, der Gag an der ganzen Geschichte, wenn das funktioniert, also sprich,
wenn, hier sieht man es doch, wenn das hier funktioniert, dass ich hier rüber quasi
meine 10G-Karte anbinden kann, wohlgemerkt, die 10G-Karte kann maximal, theoretisch, also
ein PCI-Express, eine PCI-Express 2.0, das ist 2.0, Lane packt 500 Megabyte die Sekunde,
so, ungefähr, und, ähm, das heißt, ein X2-Slot packt im optimalsten Fall, ja, also sprich,
wenn die, äh, wenn die Sonneneinstrahlung nicht zu groß ist, und der Mond im rechten
Winkel zu irgendwas, dann packt die maximal 1000 Megabyte die Sekunde, das ist natürlich
schon weniger als 10 Gigabit, 10 Gigabit sind 1250 Megabyte die Sekunde, aber damit kann
ich leben, scheiß drauf, und wenn wir jetzt mal von realistischen, wenn wir jetzt mal
von realistischen Sachen ausgehen, ja, nur, weil du ein theoretisches Maximum über den
PCI-Express-Slot kriegst, von 1000 MB die Sekunde, weiß das nicht, dass praktisch 1000
MB die Sekunde ankommen, also, ich denke mal, wir kriegen irgendwie sowas um, also ich hab
keine Ahnung was wir kriegen, wenn wir über 5G kriegen ist das nice, wenn wir über 5G
kriegen ist das nice, weil alles andere hast du eh schwierig zu saturaten, zu auszulassen,
zu saturaten, Alter, also wir saturaten das jetzt, gut, also soviel zum Build, das erste
was wir machen müssen, bevor ich jetzt weiter labere, fangen wir damit nämlich schon an,
weil das dauert wieder 10 Minuten, wir müssen erstmal was drauf installieren, auf der Kiste,
ich muss jetzt mal gucken wo ist meine Elgato, also ich hab das Board schon ausgepackt, das
liegt schon hier, ich hab ne SSD dran gemacht, da ist noch ein Ubuntu drauf, aber das machen
wir platt, da weiß ich nicht für was es verwendet wurde und was es genau macht, und ich schalte
euch jetzt mal um, kurz, auf Elgato Stellz, warte mal, ich hab ne, wir machen das super,
aber wir machen das super special, kann ich jetzt nicht noch Display Capture machen hier
drinne, Display Capture, machen wir hier dahinter, ne machen wir hier drüber, und machen das
Display Capture machen wir kleiner, und dann machen wir ihn hier weg, ok, ja, ich mach
mal, ich baue mal den USB-Stick dran, dass ich den erstmal auch verwenden kann, da hat
er die Kiste, brauche ich mal, also, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, oder ich hol, ich hol
der extra Taster
dann hämmere ich jetzt mal ein paar Tasten, in der Hoffnung, dass ich ins Bios komme
Kato stellen
jetzt, jetzt
super jetzt
aus, an und Knöpfe spammen
angehen
komm on brah
jetzt kann man Tasten spammen
ich muss euch übrigens was zeigen noch mal
ihr seht das jetzt
wir sehen auch wie man das, da muss ich die Kamera hinstellen
das ist logistisch gerade nicht möglich
so jetzt hört er mich wieder
ihr habt mich nicht gehört, weil ich auf der Erde rumgekrabbelt bin
so ich zeige euch mal was
und zwar
Enter Setup
ich mach mal die Display Capture weg, braucht kein Mensch oder
und zwar, was die ganz toll gemacht haben
ich hab schon mal auf Twitter gepostet
was die ganz toll gemacht haben
also Leute, hier kann man einstellen
im Bios kann man einstellen
wie viele CPU Kerne man verwenden möchte
und man hat hier Auswahl zwischen
Disabled und Enabled
also, was wollt ihr haben
wie viele CPU Kerne dürften es sein
ich muss mein OBS als Vorschau verwenden
das ist ziemlich eklig
so, ok, wir booten jetzt vom USB Stick
gut, USB
Ubuntu haben wir drauf
kann man irgendwie sagen, wenn man booten will
ah ja, direkt so
booten
booten USB Stick, gut
install
das geht schnell, das dauert so, keine Ahnung
wie lange dauert so ein Install, 10 Minuten
5 Minuten, geht immer zackisch
wir installieren das Ganze in Englisch
wir sind nicht in den United States
wir sind in Europa
nicht in Kokonaland
wir sind in Germany
ja, Sprachsettings ok, Keyboard, zack
wir haben eine deutsche Tastatur
ja, wir haben auch einen Ölkey
Ölkey pressen wir auch, alles gut
nein, nein, nein, wir sind keine Franzosen
wir haben kein Dings, ich weiß gar nicht mal wie das heißt
wie heißt das?
dieses E mit dem Dings drüber
Accent
wahrscheinlich heißt das nicht
Accior oder sowas in Französisch
Packetstrich
das ist ja ja toxic
das heißt schon so mit dem Dings drüber
wir machen jetzt nicht den Akt, wie wir das letzte Mal gemacht haben
zu Ubuntu installieren
wir machen jetzt einfach ganz normale Testinstallation
ohne irgendwie großartige Verschlüsselung
ohne Booten, ohne Passwort beim Booten
einfach Ubuntu drauf geklatscht
und so ist es
das heißt, dass er irgendwie keine DHCP Adresse kriegt
warum kriegst du keine DHCP Adresse?
was ist da los?
das Netzwerkkabel hat richtig reingemacht
Kabel?
hat das Netzwerkkabel nicht richtig reingemacht?
hat das Netzwerkkabel nicht richtig dran gehabt?
das ist ja Ethernet SSService EAS
am besten ist immer noch aktuell
wie haben sie es genannt?
es gab doch mal so eine Zeit
da war alles SSService, Software SSService
Backend SSService
dann kamen sie irgendwie mit Funktion SSService
sonst war es jetzt Microservices
jetzt ist es mittlerweile Serverless
Hostname
rare Parot
was machen wir für eine Hostname?
wir brauchen irgendwas schönes
wir brauchen irgendeinen dummen Hostname
Roffelman
Roffelcopter
das haben wir glaube ich schon
Roffelman, das finde ich gut
User
Grandiosus
Highly secure Passport
das wird niemals irgendjemand knacken
nie
das ist zu riesig
für alle Rechner
in diesem Universum zusammen
ich habe es doch sogar angezeigt
dass es 1,2,3,4,5,6 ist
ich weiß, dass da was drauf ist
wir wollen es jetzt einfach drüber installieren
einfach in your face
use entire disk
wir wollen es auch auf die SSD machen
nicht auf den Flashspeicher, von dem wir installieren
Passport leaked
das war die Installation
jetzt muss er installieren
wozu LVM?
das Ding wird danach eh wieder weggeschmissen
der GUI Installer ist nicht angenehmer
der Server hat übrigens gar keinen GUI Installer
welches Dateisystem für NAS
da bin ich mir noch nicht so ganz schlüssig
ich spekuliere ja wieder drauf
ZFS drauf zu machen
wie auf meiner
anderen Kiste
die die mit ein bisschen mehr Kiste
auf der anderen Kiste
die die mit ein bisschen mehr Kern
und die die mit ein bisschen mehr RAM
und die die mit ein bisschen mehr Platten
also die andere Kiste hat hier irgendwie 48G
RAM und
8 Xeonkerne
und 3x10T Platten
da ist ZFS drauf
und das flutscht halt auch richtig
ich lieb euch klar auch hier ein bisschen drauf
ZFS drauf zu machen
weil ZFS
geht auch mit weniger RAM
also das ist so ein
so ein Mysterium das ZFS mindestens
16G mindestens 32G
braucht
ja das brauchst du wenn du erstens
wenn du sowas wie die Duplication machst da kommst du nicht
drum herum da hast du gar keine Chance sonst ist das
mega langsam
und das brauchst du auch wenn du halt
da ordentlich
wenn du da ordentlich Zugriffe drauf hast
und nicht nur 2-3 Leute die das daheim benutzen
wenn du da irgendwie gar keine Ahnung
200 Leute drauf zugreifen hast oder sowas
und das auch dementsprechend
viel in RAM buffern soll
was ZFS gerne macht
und du dann auch zusätzliche
Sachen hast wie
dass du diese
ZFS hat halt einen ganz coolen Algorithmus
der hat ne Liste von Files die besonders oft
benutzt werden und ne Liste von Files
die zuletzt benutzt wurden
oder zuletzt geschrieben wurden
oder so ne Mischung da draus das heißt so ne Kombination
daraus bedeutet ihr kriegt eure
Dateien eigentlich immer relativ
immer relativ schnell
bei ZFS
das ist ne Datei die oft benutzt wird
dann kriegt ihr sie schnell weil sie wahrscheinlich schon im RAM liegt
legt es ne Datei die ihr eben grad geschrieben habt
und jetzt wieder lesen wollt dann ist es auch schnell
ansonsten braucht man für ZFS
nicht wirklich soviel RAM
wie das immer überall geschrieben wird
wie gesagt außer man bewegt sich
nicht im privaten Umfeld da sieht das natürlich ganz anders aus
äh wieso zu langsam was
ähm Moment ich muss mal
ich kann grad nicht rüberswitchen weil ich das
Tattoo nicht am Rechner angeschlossen hab
Chat, welches ist das Style System für Nastia
wie gesagt wahrscheinlich
also jetzt hier zum ausprobieren erst mal stink normal
Installation X4 fertig
ähm
kannst du mal zeigen wie du Crypto Boot
eingerichtet hast
äh
ich hab kein Crypto Boot
auf meinem ZFS Server
wir haben aber wir haben mal nen Stream dazu
gemacht wir haben mal nen Stream dazu gemacht
der müsste beim Sebaro im Archiv sein
wir haben nen Stream dazu gemacht da haben wir es vollkommen übertrieben
da haben wir ZFS selber
kompiliert
mit den Verschlüsselungs Extensions
die es damals, die es damals neu gab
plus Root Boot von
Encrypted ZFS gemacht
das war ganz abgedreht du kannst beim Sebaro
im Archiv gucken ob du das noch findest
da ist alles dabei
wie ist deine Meinung über Festplatte als Cloudspeicher
an zum Beispiel Fritzbox
gut das ist ja kein Cloudspeicher in dem Sinn
Cloudspeicher ist für mich wenn das nicht
in deinen eigenen vier Wänden ist
und vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt bei nem Kumpel
sondern irgendwo am Arsch der Welt in nem Rechenzentrum
wo man nicht genau weiß wo
das ist für mich Cloudspeicher
wo es dich auch nicht interessieren muss
aber meine Meinung für
Festplatte an die Fritzbox ist gar nicht so schlecht
weil man einfach nur
was Simples braucht
und keine Ansprüche hat irgendwie an
besonders schnelle Performance
oder irgendwie irgendwelche
irgendwelche advanceden Topics
oder irgendwelche
irgendwelche advanceden Themen
wenn du einfach nur stinknormal
eine Platte anschließen willst
ans Netzwerk hängen und drauf zugreifen
sonderlich großartigen Speed darfst du davon nicht erwarten
ich weiß gar nicht ob die Fritzbox
mittlerweile überhaupt USB 3 hat
ja und auch
generell die CPU und alles
das ist nicht wirklich für Datentransfer
bei der Fritzbox ausgelegt
doch doch das ist Ubuntu 18
aber das ist der alte der Alternative Install
ich nehm immer das neueste Ubuntu
fertig
auf dem Desktop verwende ich kein Ubuntu
wisst ihr ja
komme ich mir irgendwie merkwürdig vor alle Hamseventure
wenn Ubuntu auf dem Desktop auf dem Server schreit
oh mein Gott Ubuntu dann nehm doch irgendwie CentOS
oder nehm doch irgendwie Debian oder nehm doch irgendwie
Zuse oder irgendwas
aber nehm doch auf keinen Fall Ubuntu für den Server
und ich denk mir so Ubuntu Desktop sagt
Ubuntu Server Poggers
installation
installation finished
continue
jetzt kann ich meine Tastatur wieder umstöpseln
jetzt gucken wir noch einmal zu wie das Ding
bootet und dann gehen wir per SSH dran
achso wir gucken erstmal was es für eine IP
kriegt
hier kriegen
und gucken was es für eine IP kriegt
der hat meine
der erkennt meine Tastatur nicht mehr jetzt
oh mein Gott
was ist denn das
mit F
warum erkennt der nach dem Boot meine Tastatur nicht mehr
aber scheiß drauf
wir brauchen gar nicht
wir brauchen gar nicht mehr die Tastatur
denn
ich stöpsel das mal um
wir können einfach per SSH drauf zugreifen
und zwar
da müssen wir jetzt erstmal kurz gucken
was das Ding für ne
eh
ah
das war doch schon
dhcp server alias
ehm
wo ist es denn
siehts irgendjemand
was ist das
da sollte sich eigentlich mit
Roffelmann melden
vielleicht ist es ja das
das sollte sich aber eigentlich sollte sich das
mit Roffelmann melden warum meldet sich das nicht
mit Roffelmann
wir hätten zur Auswahl Roffelmann oder
das ist eher das neue
ehm 144
vielleicht auch 144
ich hab keine Ahnung
ah
Passport
das ist er
der Roffelmann
also was hat das jetzt für ne App hier 214
warum
der sich da nicht ordentlich mit dem
Postname Roffelmann gemeldet hat weiß ich nicht
aber das ist der Roffelmann
so
der Roffelmann ist am Start
der Roffelmann kriegt jetzt erstmal Updates
das macht man immer
immer nachdem man Ubuntu
oder irgendwas, irgendein LILOX Server
Dingsbums, Gedöns, eigentlich egal
immer erstmal Updates machen
achja
und AbtGet ist outdated
Abt ist der neue Shit
so
ich würde vorschlagen
wir machen jetzt erstmal
ja aber das ist eigentlich egal
Sebaro, der weiß doch trotzdem wie sein
Hausname ist
aber ich merke mir jetzt einfach 144 SS
der kriegt ja die gleiche IP wieder
ich würde sagen bevor wir jetzt mit dem Netzwerk
Dings anfangen machen wir eine Sache noch
wir testen mal
egal wie schnell die SSD ist
Max was hältst du von Plex
ich persönlich
verstehe den
Anwendungszweck von Plex nicht
ich weiß was man mit Plex macht
man streamt Videos
aber was für Videos
streamt ihr damit
ich meine
für sowas wie Amazon Video ist es nicht zu gebrauchen
für Netflix braucht man nicht
für die ganzen
Videodienste gibt es
Filme, Serien, aber welche Filme, Serien
Netflix, Amazon Video
da gibt es eine App für
wenn du ein Android TV hast
kannst du dir die mit der App angucken
und wahrscheinlich auch nicht
über Plex
der einzige Grund den ich sehe
was man aber zu betreiben
ist eigentlich
dass man Gerippte
bzw.
sorgfältig
angeforderte Sicherheitskopien
die Freunde
bei einem Offsite lagern
auf seinem Plex speichert
das ist eigentlich
wie ich mir das vorstellen kann
wofür Plex da ist
ich habe ehrlich gesagt für Plex keinen Anwendungszweck
ich gucke mal
für euch über Amazon Video
und das ist
auf dem Shield TV gibt es eine ganz gute App für
die Amazon App ist echt ganz okay
also ich habe bis jetzt noch nicht
die
ich habe bis jetzt noch nicht so die Notfallspürung
mit Plex zu installieren
das dachte ich mir, dass ihr alle eure Sicherheitskopien
über
Plex verwaltet
gibt es das Wort überhaupt mainly
ich meine nicht manly
gerade auf der Arbeit immer so wenn wir
mit irgendeinem
wir mussten englisch
wir mussten letzten mit so einem polnischen Call
dann telefonieren weil wir da irgendwas gehorstet haben
und
da kannst du mit denen entweder
polnisch reden oder halt englisch
und
ihr habt glücklicherweise einen
der ist halb
NA
und
der ruft dann immer an
da bin ich ganz froh drum
ich kriege immer schon Anfälle wenn ich auf der
auf der Gamescom immer
aber nach dem zweiten Tag gehts eigentlich
und was ihr in dem Stream macht
ich versuche
ein
Netzwerk mit
Verpackung zu setzten
das Ziel ist
es sollte
10 Gigabit Ethernet haben
es sollte teuer sein
es sollte silenzig sein
es sollte gute
Leistung geben
ähm
Magic Hyper
Naisu Build
und ich weiß nicht ob es funktionieren wird
und es sollte teuer sein
teuer ist der Hauptgrund warum
ich dieses Build gemacht habe
ok
also
schieb
so
jetzt
jetzt gucken wir mal
also wir probieren das mal aus
also wir haben
System
Platte, wo ist sie hier
430 G
frei, wir machen, wir
wir drehen jetzt einfach mal hier eine Runde
rum
wir drehen jetzt mal eine Runde rum
Low Power Consumption
yes
ähm
I have Energy Meter
attached and currently it has
only
6.3
Watts Idle
it's really low
it's only a dual core
Celeron
it sucks
in performance if you want to do
something
big
ok
6.3 ist übel Pogu
ok wir drehen jetzt mal
irgendwie keine Ahnung, wir drehen jetzt einfach mal
wie schnell die Platte ist
ähm
also von DevZero
drehen wir mal nach
test.image
oder irgendwie sowas
Blocksize 1M und wir machen
mal 5000
mal 1M also 5GB
drehen wir mal 5GB
kann mir das ja abgucken, ich habe das nämlich
vorhin hier extra aufgemacht
weil ich mir immer nicht die Optionen merken kann
für die Idee, ich kann mir auch was verrecken diese
Optionen für die Idee nicht merken
ups
gut, ach schreibt man das
klein
serio
lull
ok ich glaube wir müssen ein bisschen mehr schreiben
dass wir ungefähr wissen
was die SSD hinkriegt
ohne rumgecache
machen wir mal, kommen wir mal an 15G
probieren wir mal aus wie schnell das Ding ist
15G also
ok das geht am Anfang ein bisschen runter
weil der Cache voll wird von der SSD
da können wir aber nichts dagegen machen
wie der Controller intern cached
also laut Benchmarks ist
warum braucht man FDataSync
und NordTrunk, weil ich es kopiert habe
von der Seite und der Unterschied
was FDataSync macht kann ich dir sagen
NordTrunk weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht
FDataSync macht, dass du
quasi wartest
bis die Daten auf der Platte angekommen sind
du kannst ja
quasi auch Async schreiben, du kannst auch sagen
hier Betriebssystem schreibe
und dann kann das sein, dass das auch erstmal in einem Cache landet
und nicht direkt auf die Flasche
auf die Platte geflasht ist
wenn du Sync angibst heißt das
der wartet bis es auch wirklich auf der Platte angekommen ist
M2 SSD, nein
SATA
SATA ist das
also
haben wir
also sagen wir mal, die SSD schafft
ungefähr 500 MB die Sekunde
das ist jetzt
das ist okay, für eine SATA SSD
mehr geht da eh nicht
viel oder?
6G ist glaube ich Maximum
oder?
also irgendwie
250, 500
es würde noch ein bisschen näher gehen, so 650
gehen wahrscheinlich in dem Dreh
ne Quatsch, 700
aber ist egal, mehr schafft die SSD nicht
genau
also mal 500
ich denke mal lesen und schreiben
ist relativ ähnlich
aber das ist okay für die SSD
das heißt, sind wir allein schon
mit der SSD, können wir das Pfeiltransfer
mäßig gar nicht testen, wie viel wir hinkriegen
weil die SSD das gar nicht hinkriegt
und da sind wir schon dabei
wir würden es irgendwie schaffen
unsere 10G Netzwerkarte anzusprechen
wir könnten in den Rechner wahrscheinlich gar nicht so ohne weiteres
etwas einbauen, dass wir wirklich auch 10G
vollkriegen
okay, aber wir wissen schon
wieviel die SSD ungefähr packt
das ist ganz praktisch
ich installiere mal ein paar Dinge
die man auf jeden Fall brauchen
H, Top, D, Stats
Suspension
was brauchen wir noch, lass mal überlegen
was brauchen wir noch
weiß ich nicht
reicht
IP-Perf brauchen wir noch
Watch Sleepy, das können wir auch machen
das Problem ist, ich habe hier drinnen
nur 8G
RAM
das heißt, wir können eine kleine Datei
wir können uns eine
RAM-Disk machen, irgendwie so 4G oder so was
und dann mal drüber schieben
das können wir machen
wobei es so richtig schön sehen
was man so für Übertragungsraten hat
tut man eigentlich nur, weil man richtig
Fettendateien
überträgt, weil dann
dann sind halt auch alle Caches voll
und dann siehst du halt auch, was so im
Durchschnitt sequenziell rumkommt
und da ist es meistens mit
4, 5G gar nicht getan
deswegen habe ich jetzt auch 15 einfach mal gemacht
IP-Perf
brauchen wir noch
IP-Perf 3, bitte schön
mit IP-Perf werden wir jetzt testen
ich zeige euch mal, wie das jetzt aussieht
da kann man nämlich sagen, IP-Perf
das ist jetzt noch hier gerade mit
mit 100
äh
1000 mit
wahrscheinlich 100, weil das Kabelkacke
ist
also aktuell
ist das angebunden
mit 1000, ne doch
1000, ne warte mal wo steht es denn
100 MBit
also
die Onboard-Karte mit dem Kackkabel
sackt ein bisschen
aber
von der Idee her
sieht es dann so aus, du kannst hier sagen
IP-Perf minus
dann lauscht er
und dann sagste
achso ja, ich muss erstmal auf meinen Server drauf
auf meine
das da, also hier
POGChamp ist meine
Achtkernkiste
die fette
die fette Kiste ist das
IC
ähm
144 haben wir gesagt, ne
genau, und man sieht ungefähr
das theoretische Maximum kommt auch hin
95, also das ist
100 MBit Verbindung, das ist okay
so, das interessiert uns
natürlich überhaupt nicht, wir wollen ja 10G
haben
das heißt, jetzt kommt der Moment
der Wahrheit, wenn ich nicht irgendwas vergessen hab
jetzt versuche ich mal die
10G-Karte
einzubauen
bin ich ja mal
gespannt
ähm
also man kann sich das übrigens ganz gut anzeigen lassen
man kann sagen
LSPCI, dann sieht man was drin ist
und da siehst du was
für Geräte in einem Rechner
reingestöpselt sind
wobei die Übersicht ziemlich kacke ist
beste Übersicht ist das hier
LSPCI
minus T, dann malt er so
nen
dann malt er so nen
Tree, so nen
wo du siehst was für
Geräte wie wo
angehängt sind, das heißt ich hoffe
ich hoffe, dass wenn ich die 10G-Karte
da reinstecke, ich muss jetzt gleich mal runterfahren
weil hot geplugged
kann das Ding bestimmt nicht, das probiere ich auch nicht
aus, da geht noch irgendwas kaputt
und dann hoffe ich, dass hier irgendwo drin steht die 10G-Karte
was gibt's hier
was wird hier gemacht, wir basteln
ein Nass, und zwar ein 10Gb Nass
ein 10Gb Nass, ich habe extra aufgesprüht
was besonders stromsparend ist, was silent ist
was 10G packt, was
5Gb plus packt hoffe ich mal
und was nicht so teuer ist
das machen wir hier
ok, ich fahre mal runter
und schließe das Ding an
also
Roffelmann
aus ist
ist die Musiklautstärke eigentlich ok?
die schwankt übelst, ne? die Musiklautstärke
jetzt ist sie wieder leise
vorher ist sie wieder, ah gut, die sind auch gerade vorbei
ok, der Roffelmann
ist aus
ich mache jetzt mal die 10G-Karte rein
Jungs, weiß ich mach erstmal den Adapter
rein
und dann nehme ich die 10G-Karte rein
Sebaru, ich würde noch mal 2 Minuten warten, da siehst du nicht
ob das weiter geht oder nicht, da nehme ich die 10G-Karte
nicht erkennt
warum habe ich es denn?
weiß dass ihr mich echt hört, weil ich krabble
auf der Erde rum
Frau Schraubenzieher
also
es leuchtet
an der Seite von diesem komischen Slot
hinten an der Netzwerkkarte
leuchtet nichts
das ist aber auch erstmal nicht schlimm
weil die meistens erst anfangen zu leuchten
wenn der Treiber geladen ist
das heißt, sollte das Ding anfangen zu leuchten
ist schon mal
ein guter Hinweis dafür
dass das funktionieren könnte
so, gucken wir mal ob der wieder gestartet ist jetzt
der Roffelmann
gucken wir mal ob der Roffelmann wieder da ist
wenn das Ding anfängt zu brennen
dann ist RIP
oh, die Karte leuchtet
die Karte leuchtet
die 10G-Karte leuchtet
mal gucken ob er es auch erkannt hat
oh, jetzt bin ich gespannt
wenn das gehen würde, wäre das so krass
das ist das billigste und schnellste Nassbild
was du dir vorstellen kannst
da
Alter, das funktioniert
das funktioniert
oh, das hyper
hyper
was auch immer
krasser Shit
boah, ist das nice
ich hab gedacht wir müssen sonst
wie rumbasteln wahrscheinlich noch was im BIOS einstellen
oder sowas
Alter, das ist mega nice
ok, ähm
das heißt, auch mit if-config
haben wir jetzt eine zweite Netzwerkkarte drinne
da, guckt wir haben eine zweite Netzwerkkarte drinne
und die zweite Netzwerkkarte kann
pock-hu
die zweite Netzwerkkarte kann
10Gbps
und die ist
das sieht nicht so aus als wäre Link down
ehrlich gesagt, das blinkt vorne
Moment, die Anzeige verwirrt mich immer
ist der Link jetzt down oder nicht
also für mich sieht die Netzwerkkarte nicht aus
als wäre der Link down
Link detected
no
who cares
also die Karte ist nicht down
der Link, der leuchtet
ich seh den leuchten, der Link ist nicht down
das ist Bullshit was da steht
so, ähm
ja, dann würd ich sagen, dann geben wir uns mal
in der IP
ähm
oh, oh, der steinex, der hat
die krassen neuen Tools am Start
ich bin ja immer noch einer, der sich angewöhnen muss
kein if-config mehr zu verwenden
obs, wenn man so richtig schreibt
ähm
Mode down, egal
da lassen wir uns mal nicht von ablenken jetzt
weil der Link ist nicht down, ich seh's
der blinkt, er blinkt
gerade debated, ja
huge, huge debate
ok, if-config
ich kann, Leute, ich krieg's
ich geb mir wirklich Mühe, ich versuch das auch auf der Arbeit
jeden Tag, kein if-config mehr zu verwenden
sondern IP
ähm
ich mach jetzt einfach, ich mach jetzt mal das
wo ich aus dem Kopf weiß, wie es geht
if-config
die Karte
die kriegt ne IP, also irgendwie
Punkt, ähm
irgendwas außerhalb von DHCP
Range, keine Ahnung
2.60
kriegt das Ding jetzt mal
24 ab
zack und da isse
und wenn wir jetzt pingen können
wissen wir, dass die Karte
easy
die ist nicht down, die debated uns nur
guck, die sagt immer noch link down, aber
aber
das ist debate
guck, link down
von wegen, moment, jetzt ist es ab
ach stimmt, ich hab's ja, ich hab ja auch grad gesagt
ab
aber es funktioniert
wir können ping, bam
nice
sehr nice, sehr ulti
gamer329, wenn das so einfach ist, passiert bestimmt gleich irgendwas
wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich passiert gleich irgendwas
da geh ich auch davon aus
ok, wir gucken jetzt nochmal ein, wir gucken uns nochmal
mit lspci die Ausgabe an
was der denn sagt
melanox
was der denn sagt, wie der connected ist
die Ausgabe ist hier
typisch uralt linux tools mäßig
ähm
eklig
und
man muss da sich ein bisschen durchkämpfen
ist das gerade, das ist kopfer, jaja das ist
dyogon attached kopfer, deswegen muss ich das Ding auch auf der
Erde so hin und her rücken, weil ich mal
ich find das Modul
nicht
ich hab genug, ich weiß genau, ich hab genug
Module für den
da, also auf jeden fall noch eins
auf jeden fall noch eins, das weiß ich, weil ich
ich werd mir bestimmt nicht 3
Module bestellt haben, ja, eventuell hab ich mir 4 Module
bestellt und
ich hab ein Glasfaserkabel da am Start
ich hab ein Modul am Start, aber
ich finde das zweite Modul nicht, was ich noch übrig haben
müsste, dementsprechend muss ich das jetzt
bei dyogon attached dran machen und das dyogon
attached Kabel ist plus 3 Meter, also spricht
deswegen muss ich jetzt immer so viel auf der Erde rumrutschen und kanns mir nicht
auf den Treibtisch stellen
fail
was ist denn, was du
was ist das, was du
aufhast
das ist meine Linux
VM und ich bin grade
auf meinem NAS eingeloggt
beziehungsweise auf dem, was mein
neues NAS werden wird
so, also schauen wir mal
was der sagt
mit wie viel er verbunden ist, also ich
erwarte jetzt, dass
der, also das ist
also ich erwarte jetzt, dass
die Karte mit
zweifach
PCI express drin ist
und irgendwo
müsste es hier sowas geben wie
Linkstatus und Linkkabel
Alter
ich kann dieses Wort nicht aussprechen, ich lass es einfach
bleiben, also sprich, was die Karte kann
und was der Link ausgehandelt hat
also genau, guck
das ist das, was die Karte sagt, was die kann
die sagt
achtfach
was eigentlich keinen Sinn ergibt, das ist nur eine Vierfachkarte
doppelter G-Bate
die erzählt einfach Stuss in die Karte
das ist nur eine Vierfachkarte
egal
und ausgehandelt
hat er zweifach, das
wiederum ist vollkommen korrekt
ich bin auf dem Roffelmann eingeloggt, genau
für was brauchst du 10 Genas?
es geht
und weil es mittlerweile günstig ist
warum nicht?
das ist nice
sagen wir so 250, 300 Euro ohne Platten
ok, jetzt kommt der Moment
der Wahrheit, wir schauen mal
wie schnell
der ganze Spaß ist
IP Perf
und das machen wir
das machen wir mit UDP
weil
ich will nichts verschenken an Speed
und da muss ich mal gucken
ich hab nämlich auch einen Benchmark Befehl dafür
irgendwo, egal
kriegen wir auch so hin
IP Perf
Connect zu Kleint
60 habe ich der gegeben
Connect zu Kleint 60
gucken wir mal ohne UDP
was ist das?
der geht nicht über die richtige Karte
der kann nicht über die richtige Karte gehen
der geht über die falsche Karte
das ergibt
das ergibt sonst keinen Sinn
der geht über die falsche Karte
der geht über die
über die 100 MBit
über die Onboard Karte geht der
100 Pro
anders kann das nicht sein
wie sagt man das IP Perf
dass der irgendwie
Interface
Bind to a specific
Bind
wie hieß der Kram
E Ending Star hier so
Unavailable
warum
wie geht das
3 Bind Interface
hat da mal jemand ein Beispiel
für
muss ich das noch nie Binden an
achso dann gibst du die IP von dem Ding an
ist ja gut
immer noch
das kann doch nicht sein
das geht über die falsche Karte
das stimmt nicht
wisst ihr was ich jetzt mach
ich fahre das andere Interface einfach runter
das ist zwar nicht
dir weiß als letzter Schluss
aber ich fahre das andere Interface einfach runter
dann wissen wir was Sache ist
also locken wir uns nochmal auf dem Roffelmann ein
da brauchst du 2 und für die
eigentlich brauch ich im lokalen Netz überhaupt keine guten Kabellen
so weit von der Theorie hier zumindest
das ist egal weil das ist das gleiche Netz
so
wir fahren jetzt einfach die 2. Netzwerk
die 1. Netzwerkkarte runter hier
E01
down
jetzt gehen wir über die richtige
jetzt gehen wir über die richtige Karte
das ist immer noch knapp eine Gigabit
das liegt aber daran weil ich es von meiner VM mache
und die VM hat nur eine Gigabit Karte drin
das kann überhaupt nicht schneller gehen
ich geh jetzt mal hier unten auf meinen Server drauf
und schnapp mir mal
jetzt machen wir einen UDP Test
IP Perf
ich sag immer IP Perf
IP Perf geht irgendwie
einfacher
von der Zunge irgendwie
ok
also wir machen jetzt erstmal wie gesagt wir wollen UDP testen
wir wollen
ich glaub dann einfach wieder
wie gehabt die IP
und dann musste man irgendwie noch
warte mal
IP Perf
da hab ich letztens erst danach geguckt
IP Perf UDP
Performance
hallo
ja genau das hab ich mir
letztes mal schon eingestellt
ach genau Minus B war es
da sagt man was er für eine Bandbreite testen soll
oder was genau macht
Minus B
bandwidth
ok
also Minus B
10.000
oder
10.000 M
BAM
Achtung Leute
jetzt gehts ab
jetzt gibt es jetzt wird High Speed
eingeschaltet
ok es ist
die Anzeige ist merkwürdig
die Anzeige ist irgendwie
merkwürdig
ich trau der Sache hier irgendwie mehr als der da oben
also wir haben jetzt
6,3 Gigabit
das ist natürlich
ultra nice
warum ich nicht ausflippe
ist ich bin ein bisschen
überrascht weil es die
warum unterscheiden sich denn bitte schön
an die Dinger
oh weil der
weil der Dinger losted
ah der losted
losted Pakete
der losted Pakete
ja das ist natürlich
das ist natürlich crap
der losted Pakete
das ist
Suck
aber das liegt wahrscheinlich einfach daran weil der
ja gut die Hälfte
na klar
na klar verliert er die Hälfte
die eben nicht so viel
nicht so viel können ja
wenn ich 1000 mach loste der glaube ich
keine Pakete
oder
warum loste der überhaupt Pakete
das glaube ich nicht ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
dass der ernsthaft
40% Pakete verliert
das ergibt für mich jetzt
relativ wenig Sinn
wir machen das mal mit TCP
wir machen das mit TCP
ich glaube das ist
ja guck mal das kann nicht sein
ja ohne Minus B geht
ach doch
ja gut 16
16 das ist natürlich ein bisschen lahm jetzt
ich trau der Sache wirklich das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
ey wenn ich
40% Paket lost hätte da könnte der da mal über das
H irgendwie gescheit fast flüssig tippen
wir machen mal TCP Test
ja das ist doch
realistischer aus dann stimmt
dann ist der UDP Test
schon richtig
weil guck mal wir kriegen
mit dem TCP Test kriegen wir
5,4 Gigabit durch
und mit dem UDP Test
kriegen wir
maximal durchgepumpt 6,36
und das
passt schon
das passt schon ungefähr
wenn der TCP Test 5,3 macht
und der UDP Test 6,3
das ergibt schon irgendwie Sinn
und wir hätten
bei einem 50
beknackt das ist
bei einem 50% Paket lost
da wird der Test dann aber ordentlich laufen
ok
keine Ahnung aber
das sieht
also die Zahlen hier sehen mir ehrlich gesagt relativ
relativ realistisch aus für das
weil wir haben maximal
bekommen wir
wie viel ist denn das hier
das hier
2 also das hier
sind Gigabit
zu Megabytes
was ist denn in Firefox los
sehr hässlich also 800 MB
die Sekunde das deckt
sich ungefähr mit dem
welche IP
Version ist das
ist eine gute Frage
wir können ja mal die Verbindung umgedreht
machen vom Roffelmann auf den
auf die fette Kiste
also auf dem Roffelmann ist es IP
Version
3.1.3
und auf dem Server ist es
auf der fette Kiste ist es IP 3.1.3
ok da gibt es keine Probleme
aber wir haben auf keinen Fall
50% Paket lost
wir haben wahrscheinlich gar keinen Paket lost
den Server müsste ich nicht
mit U starten der listen an beiden
das ist neu früher musste man das machen
aber jetzt sehen wir
wie groß sind die UDP Pakets
ahnung
keine Ahnung
weiß ich nicht wie groß
soll ich das wissen
wahrscheinlich 1490
oder irgendwie sowas
Stackoverflow schlägt vor
die Length zu erhöhen
ja dann machen wir das doch mal
wenn Stackoverflow das vorschlägt dann ist das meistens
nicht verkehrt
ja das sieht das doch schon
besser aus da hinten
aber da oben immer noch nicht
das ist
na gut wir sollten vielleicht auch was realistisches angehen
Bandbreite wir haben wir versuchen
da zwar 10k drüber zu pumpen
aber wir pumpen ja gar
nicht 10k drüber so viel passt ja gar nicht drüber
wir haben never
haben wir 50% Paket lost auf
gar keinen Fall das wirds zu
spüren 50% Paket lost
da könnte ich hier noch nicht mal ohne
ruckeln was schreiben richtig
50% Paket lost ist quasi Netzwerk im Arsch
das haben wir auf gar keinen Fall
das können wir einfach mal ausprobieren na gut wenn ich was download
bringt mir das jetzt nichts
der gehts kleiner man das kann man machen
aber die TCP Messung ist schon
ein bisschen besser
der hängt hier auch immer auf 60%
was passiert eigentlich wenn ich da 50
Gigabit drüber jage
genau das gleiche okay
wisst ihr was ich glaube einfach mal
was hier steht weil egal
wie groß wir das machen was wir an Bandbreite
drüber jagen es ist immer gleich viel
ich hab keine Ahnung was
das haben wir wir haben kein
wir haben keinen Paket lost in der Höhe
gar niemals niemals
kennt irgendjemand was vergleichbares zu
IP Perf was man
verwendet normalerweise immer das
aber vielleicht gibt es hier was anderes
extrem UDP Paket lost
was schreiben sie denn auf GitHub
probier es doch mal von einem Server
auf deine VM ob der lost
gleich ist
ja das ist eine gute Idee
wisst ihr was wir mal ausprobieren
wir probieren es mal wir probieren es mal lokal
wir probieren es mal lokal aus
wir probieren es mal lokal aus was dann passiert
Moment ich bin verwirrt
ja ich hab
das lokal nicht
doch irgendwas vergessen
das ist jetzt lokal
lokal haben wir kein lost
aber lokal haben wir lustigerweise
die Messung ist irgendwie ein bisschen
so rigged keine Ahnung
also ich mein wir haben lokal
wir haben lokal weniger Übertragungsrate
wie von einem
also der also der
der UDP Messung trau ich nicht
der trau ich nicht irgendwie
ich mein wenn wir lokal
wenn wir lokal TCP machen
kriegen wir wahrscheinlich ein paar
ja guck das ist lokal
das ist quasi
quasi einmal PCI rein durch die CPU
PCI raus oder wenn überhaupt
Eiskräuter das war übelst
beschiss die SSD auf AliExpress
die war nur 32G groß
oder so
super und cool wie viele Leute
das ist übelst nice
bei dir ist dasselbe Scheiß ausgekommen
also ich glaube dem Packetloss
an der Stelle nicht
in dem Hovana
das startet ja nur mehrere
Connections
hast du die Latenz vom Stream verbessert
ich hab
die Latenz eingehalten
also ich glaub das nicht
ganz ehrlich Leute
wenn ihr mal 50% Packetloss gesehen habt
in echt
dann sind das keine 50% Packetloss
guck mal wenn ich 50% Packetloss hätte
dann könnte ich nicht mal hier irgendwas
dann könnte ich nicht mal hier irgendwas aufmachen
und das würde ordentlich ordentlich
das würde überhaupt nicht funktionieren
das ist genau der Rübel
glaube ich auch das ist fail
also gehen wir mal von aus
dass wir aktuell
scheiß mal drauf
auf die Geschichte hier
ignorieren wir mal den Packetloss
weil der ist nicht
den gibt es nicht
ähm
und jagen wir mal
und jagen wir mal ein Gigabit
drüber da sehen wir wir kommen auf
6,35 Gigabit
ungefähr
was
mega nice ist
SSH Commands werden aber
nicht über UDP versendet
das ist vollkommen egal
da müsste ja jedes TCP Packet
irgendwie bis das wirklich da ist
pünkt mal noch angefordert werden
das würdest du merken
das würdest du vor allem beim tippen merken
es sieht auf dem System
wenn du auf dem Weg zum System 50% Packetloss hast
sieht das hier nicht so flüssig aus wenn du irgendwas tippst
da hast du echt Probleme
das ist Debate
das stimmt nicht
ich hatte schon das richtige Issue auf GitHub
ja guck das haben
andere hier auch noch
Issue still exists
Perhaps
Don't do
Minus L
Und was ist jetzt die Lösung
Was hast du für Platten drin
Aktuell habe ich nur die System SSH drin
es kommen dann 10TB
Seagate Platten dran
die sind bei mir noch gerade in der anderen Kiste drin
Don't do
Ja ok wo ist denn jetzt
Warum hat er das jetzt
geklost
Ne 9G kriege ich
garantiert nicht hin
das Ding ist bloß pizzi express x2
angebunden also ich könnte maximal
maximal könnte ich
1000mb die Sekunde kriegen
ja Smaller haben wir doch
aber hier
was sagt er Don't use
Smaller
Was nehmen wir denn
Ahnung
Ja spuckt viel ähnliches aus
L8
Ja L8
L8 ist ein bisschen zu klein
ist echt zu klein
L8
ist ein bisschen zu klein
ist echt zu klein
ja das ist natürlich lahm
ja aber ich update jetzt auch nicht
update ist nicht
0 ist klar
ist klar natürlich
natürlich ganz bestimmt
so fühlt sich ein Netzwerk mit 71%
an
ok
wir machen jetzt mal was anderes
wir übertragen jetzt mal
Windows Freigabe
ich kanns euch leider
von meinem
immer noch nicht zeigen also ich kanns euch nicht
von der Windows Kiste aus zeigen
weil die ist aktuell nur mit einem Gigabit angebunden
ich muss euch das
per Samba Mount von diesem Server zeigen
aber das ist im Prinzip ja kein Unterschied ob ich das von Windows mache
oder von einem Samba Mount
ok also
install Samba
wir können auch LFS mal testen
Ophelmann was hast du für Probleme?
Ophelmann was ist los?
achso ich
ich bin ja auch bescheuert
ich hab ja meine Platte
ich hab ja meine
Onboard Netzwerkkarte runter gefahren
ich hab ja meine Onboard Karte
wir machen das jetzt anders
nachdem wir jetzt ja eine Karte haben
die funktioniert
können wir auch die
können wir ja auch die Onboard Karte
vergessen
Interfaces
Netplan
Ubuntu
geh weg
oh ne ne das machen wir nicht
naja naja
Netplan machen wir nicht
netplan machen wir nicht
ah der guckt euch das mal an
ne ne ne
ich mein oh wei
es sieht eigentlich schon ganz schön simpel aus
ne
da schreiben wir jetzt einfach rein
ENP linksbums
aber jammel
das ist ne Sache wie gesagt ich bin
ich hab's ja gesagt
ich installier immer auf mein Ubuntu
das ist so eines der ersten Sachen wo ich sage
fail
äh wouz
schreibt hey ich hab das Mikroteil
hinbekommen ach
echt
soll da eigentlich kein Unterschied sein ob das von windbox
oder von windbox konfigurierst
oder von
der Weboberfläche
frinas
ja weil ich mit frinas nicht
nur nass machen
ich will ja alles möglich machen
ich will ja auch noch irgendwie
den nextloud-container oder gedöns installieren
außerdem
wozu ich brauche keine
ich brauche kein Webquay wozu
das geht mir eh auf den Keks dass ich im Webquay
rumklicken muss
ja gut dann machen wir es jetzt
halt mal mit
netplan und
kann man
wenn man den jetzt
rausnimmt
ich lasse ihn mal drinnen stehen und
starte neu und wir gucken mal ob er jetzt mit beiden
Netzwerkinterfaces hochkommt wenn er mit
beiden Netzwerkinterfaces hochkommt nehme ich
ENO1 raus
rot
wird neu gestartet
finde yaml schlimmer als xml
nein nichts ist schlimmer als xml
nein clock
ich habe nicht
geht das überhaupt
Portbinding
Link
Aggregation
das ist auch wieder so ein Ding
jeder Hersteller nennt den Kack anders
ich wusste gar nicht
dass man das einrichten kann in netplan
ich verstehe auch den Sinn ehrlich gesagt nicht
wozu es netplan überhaupt gibt
war
Netzwerkinterfaces zu kompliziert
zumal man sagen muss in systemd
also dieser networkd ist ja selbst
der ist
da nochmal drunter und der hat ja auch eigene
config files wo man ohne Probleme
achso ne das geht jetzt nicht
das war was 144
wenn er wieder neu gestartet ist
dann 144
was ist netplan überhaupt
netplan ist ein
eigentlich im Prinzip nur
ein Ding was aus yaml config
aus yaml netzwerk config
netzwerk config macht
also eigentlich das überflüssigste
überhaupt
ja das kommt hoch
nice
ok dann nehmen wir jetzt mal den kram
aus der
dann nehmen wir den hier mal raus
und reboot nochmal und dann kommen wir nur mit
der mit der 10g
netzwerkkarte hoch würde ich sagen
ich hab keine ahnung wie man netplan refresht
im laufenden betrieb, guck mal die Hexe ist auch da
moin
ich verstehe den sinn nicht davon
die daseinsberechen von netplan
naja es sieht halt
es sieht ein bisschen ordentlicher aus
ähm es ist yaml
yaml ist von naturaus
recht
eingerückt und formatiert
aber eigentlich
ist es ziemlich sinnlos
eigentlich ist es echt total überflüssig
weil standardmäßig richtest du
ja unter ubuntu und debian hast du hier
netzwerk interfaces
hast du die datei hier
und so sieht die
normalerweise aus wie du unter debian
eingerichtet hast das ist überhaupt
kein ding so und du könntest auch
du könntest auch
irgendwie etc network
du könntest auch die systemd geschichte von hand machen
das ist auch nicht viel schlimmer
und jason
ist kompatibel
yaml ist jason
man sieht es im plus nicht an und das ist kein witz
jedes jason ist valid yaml
nee umgedreht
jedes yaml ist valid jason
falsch rum
oder moment
nein schwachsinn
jedes jason ist valid yaml
so rum
ja ksc89
ok leute also
ist das eigentlich nur die eine netzwerkarte oben wunderbar
und jetzt können wir mal
samber installieren also erstmal update
update
bam
install samber
jetzt
jetzt machen wir mal eine winnaus
freigabe und kopieren da mal ein bisschen was
rüber
phobie das ist auch ein bisschen abgedreht
unübersichtlich was ich hier treibe
versuche ja immer wenn du was wissen willst
sag einfach bescheid
aber
man muss glaub ich nicht allem folgen können
so
jetzt haben wir winnaus freigabe gedürnt installiert
wobei brauchen wir eigentlich nicht
und nun
würde ich sagen
machen wir mal eine samber share
eine sache die ich mir nie merken kann
ich krieg es einfach
umverreckend nicht hin
mir einen irgendwie
aus dem kopf einen samber share
zu erstellen ich krieg es
seit über zehn Jahren ich kann mir es nicht merken
aus dem kopf es geht einfach nicht
mach mal clear bitte
hier
ist besser
einfache samber freigabe
ich suche immer danach immer
immer
und jetzt geht die seite nicht
so so was hier genau
so was hier brauchen wir
pass
wir verbrauchen
wir missbrauchen mal mnt dazu
das brauchen wir eh grad nicht
kennst du curl parrot life klar
klar kenn ich das
zeig es euch mal
für die die es nicht kennen
die
die musik ist irgendwie so leise
warte wir machen jetzt
wieder
epic music
epic
das hatten wir schon
das hatten wir noch nicht
jawoll
holst du die damit nicht fremden coding zermine
nicht wirklich
text halt
das kann ja erstmal nicht viel passieren
du kannst sogar
ich schau mal ein neues terminal auf
du kannst sogar sowas hier machen
deaf random
sowas kannst du machen
da passiert auch nichts
da holst du dir auch bullshit ins terminal
und machst vielleicht dein terminal kurz kaputt musst du es gesetten
aber das passiert nichts
so bla bla bla
trotzdem
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla
plz
Ok, ich switch jetzt mal auf Windows und gucke ob der Share prinzipiell geht, weil das immer noch von Windows am einfachsten ist.
60, ne, äh, nicht 60, 60 hatten wir ursprünglich, äh, 143, bam, public, zack, schreiben, zack, ne, nicht zack.
Ach, samba config, äh, kacke, kann ich mir nicht merken, aber lesen reicht ja erstmal.
Verstehe ich richtig, dass das Ziel ist ein Gerät mit mehreren Festplatten zu haben, auf das man per Wlan zugreifen kann.
Ne, nicht per Wlan, nicht per Wlan, per Kabel, per 10 Gigabit Kabel, 10 Gigabit, das ergibt keinen Sinn, aber trifft es am ehesten noch.
Ne, Wlan nicht, Wlan nicht, 10 Terabit Wlan, ja. Ok, ähm, was wollte ich jetzt machen?
Samba Mountain, ähm, mount, ziffs und dann, ähm, das ist wieder auch so ne Syntax, die ich mir irgendwie schlecht merken kann.
Public nach, nicht in den Ordner, ja, ich hab nen Ordner, Samba, äh, Passwort, null, Passwort, falsches mein Passwort.
Ok, also wir haben das jetzt gemacht, also das ist unser Windows-Share hier unten, das ist wie im Windows Explorer, bloß halt jetzt auf Unterlinux.
Das macht überhaupt keinen Unterschied, das ist ein Windows-Share.
So, und dann machen wir jetzt mal unser dd hin, ähm, wo haben wir eigentlich vorher hin dd'd?
Da ne, das machen wir mal weg und äh, hallo, und dd'n das mal hier hin.
Also wir erzeugen uns jetzt mal ne Datei mit 15, mit 15 Gigabyte auf diesem Windows-Laufwerk und lesen das dann vom anderen Rechner aus.
Gucken wir mal wie schnell das funktioniert.
Bekommen das, dann hast du dann auch RGB, ja, wenn du da in den verbleibenden 5 Euro Budget noch die Möglichkeit findest, RGB einzubauen, dann kannst du natürlich RGB ein, das ist so ne...
Also das Budget ist schon sehr ausgereizt, also so Spä- so Spästchen wie RGB passen da nicht mehr rein, wobei RGB müsste die Sache natürlich noch beschleunigen.
Weil es ja allzeit bekannt, dass RGB die ganze, dass alles schneller macht.
Okay, ähm, hier ist die Datei, die Datei ist 15 Gigabyte und wir lesen jetzt einfach mal, wir lesen jetzt einfach mal die Datei, wir lesen jetzt mal die Datei und schreiben sie, schreiben sie weg.
Ja, wir machen nix, wir lesen die Datei über die Windows-Freigabe, das ist jetzt von dem Rechner, das ist ne Windows-Freigabe auf den Roffelmann.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Und gucken mal wie schnell wir sind.
Nachdem wir ruht sind muss ich mal gucken, dass ich kein Mist eingebe.
Also, Input, Output, Def0, gut, passt.
Ja, das kommt ungefähr hin, das kommt ungefähr hin auf die Geschwindigkeit, ungefähr hin mit der Geschwindigkeit, die die SSD hat.
Offslash funktioniert nicht, Offslash ist kein Device, das kann ja glücklicherweise nicht passieren, aber du könntest andere Sachen.
Easy Aliexpress RGB, ja das wird funktionieren, da bist du mit 5 Euro dabei.
Okay, also, was wir easy schaffen über unsere 10G-Karte ist die SSD auszulasten, das schaffen wir.
Hm, wie machen wir das? Ich mein, ich kann mir ne RAM-Disk machen, allerdings...
Wisst ihr was, ich mach mir ne 6GB RAM-Disk, okay, das wird doch passen.
Bound, Bound, DMPFS, das ist übrigens wieder so ne Sache, wo ich ja auch immer, was ich ja auch immer gerne sag.
Ihr müsst nicht wissen, wie das Scheiß aus dem Kopf funktioniert, ihr müsst nur wissen, was ihr suchen müsst.
In dem Fall war es wichtig zu wissen, dass ihr TempFS mounten wollt.
TempFS ist das Ding für RAM-Disks und mount der Befehl zum Einhängen.
Das heißt, wenn man sagt mount-t TempFS mit Angabe zur Größe, dann kriegt man ne RAM-Disk, die dann halt 200 MB groß ist.
So, machen wir mal hier, keine Ahnung, jetzt weiß ich, wie nennen wir das Ding jetzt hier, RAM-Disk. Und der root, root RAM-Disk, nee, root RAM-Disk ist bescheuert.
Ich hab immer mal irgendwie keine Ahnung, RAM-Disk, so, da darf jeder drauf zugreifen und lesen, BAM, minus R ist leerer Ordner, Hauptsache alles BAM, so, und das hängen wir jetzt hier ein, RAM-Disk.
RAM-Disk, ne RAM-Disk von 6GB, was man jetzt auch hier direkt sieht, wir haben, achso, das füllt sich erst, je nach Füllstand, ja.
So, wir haben ne RAM-Disk von 6GB und da drehen wir jetzt nochmal unser File rein und das, da drehen wir bloß nen 5G-File rein, das sollte jetzt ziemlich schnell gehen, von der RAM-Disk, also vom RAM in die RAM-Disk.
Ja, ok, es ging, es ging schnell, auf jeden Fall. So, und jetzt machen wir noch nen Summer Mountain, dann gucken wir mal, wie schnell das Ganze jetzt kopiert.
RAM-Disk, Restart, Restart. Ach ne, hängt da Summer jetzt?
Ah, U-Mount, SMB und nochmal neu mountain. So, DD und jetzt gucken wir mal, wie schnell er den Krampel liest. Wir müssen das irgendwie mehrfach machen.
Ja, das ist doch ok. Also das dürfte so ungefähr das sein, was wir durchkriegen, 655MB übers Summer, da kann man doch echt mit leben.
655MB, das ist ein bisschen, das ist ein bisschen weniger, ein bisschen mehr als die Hälfte, ne? 655MB, das sind, ja, das ist ein bisschen mehr als die Hälfte, was maximal theoretisch mit 10G gehen würde.
Und das, genau, der Wout ist da nämlich recht, das ist im Endeffekt, kannst du an Summer auch noch viel drehen, dass das schneller wird.
Also die, ähm, der rohe Netzwerktest hat ergeben, wir können ungefähr 6,3G übertragen, ähm, und Summer hat jetzt ungefähr, was hat denn das Summer, 600, 655MB zu, äh, Gigabit, 5,24. Ja, also unser theoretisches Maximum war irgendwie 6,3, ne?
6,3, 6,37 war unser theoretisches Maximum, was wir hinkriegen und, ähm, ups, und wir kriegen davon jetzt über Summer übertragen 5,24.
Da kann man mit leben, denke ich. Da kann man mit leben. Man kriegt schnellere, also du kriegst mit keiner anderen Kombination im Prinzip mehr Speed hin auf diesem Mainboard. Oder bei dieser Preisklasse.
Kriegst, kriegst du nichts, kriegst du nichts gebacken, weil, ähm, die Alternative zu einer 10G-Karte wäre irgendwie Link Aggregation mit mehreren 1G-Ports und um das hier zu toppen, bräuchtest du dann irgendwie einen 6er Link oder so.
Ne, nicht ganz. Brauchst du den? Ja, doch. Ja, 6. Ungefähr, sag mal so, du bräuchtest 6,1G links ungefähr, um auf diesen, auf diesen Speed zu kommen. Und das kriegst du niemals in dieses Board rein.
Was ist die CPU-Auslastung? Das ist eine gute Frage, das gucken wir jetzt nochmal. Ähm, bam. Der langweilt sich.
Das juckt den überhaupt nicht. Der ist vollkommen entspannt.
Hanfwand fragt, wenn man per Kabel mit dem Ding verbunden sein muss, wäre es dann nicht praktischer, die Platten gleich in den Rechner zu bauen. Das wäre praktischer, wenn du das nur mit einem Benutzer benutzen willst. Also wenn nur du den Speicherplatz brauchst und auch nur du an diesem einen Rechner, dann ja.
Was man, wofür man aber halt auch kann das bauen. Das brauchst du zum Beispiel, wenn du einen, also im privaten Bereich jetzt, brauchst du wenn du zum Beispiel Filme, Musik, sonst was hast und im Netzwerk bereitstellen willst, dass du das von jedem Gerät abspielen kannst.
Wenn du Fernsehaufnahmen hast, die du speichern willst und dann quasi von jedem Endgerät abspielen willst. Wenn du was generell mit mehreren Benutzern scheren willst. Immer dann, im Prinzip ist der umgedrehte Fall einfacher zu beschreiben, immer dann, wenn du es nicht rein lokal haben willst.
Kann man auch 10 Gigabit SFT Link aggregaten? Ja, kann man theoretisch machen. Du kannst auch 40G Link aggregaten. Also ich habe es weder bei 10G gemacht noch bei 40G, aber ich wüsste nicht, was dagegen sprechen sollte.
Das ist Ethernet, Ethernet ist immer das gleiche, egal ob 10G oder 40G. Also wie sowas funktioniert an der Stelle. Und egal, kannst du auch und kannst du auch 5-10G Links machen oder 5-40G Links.
Da hört es halt irgendwann mal auf, wie sinnvoll das Ganze ist. Du kannst, ehrlich gesagt, Clocks HD, keine Ahnung, aber ich würde wundern, wenn das nicht funktioniert. Ups, falsch, falsch.
Meine arme kleine Katze. Ich habe gerade das Bild hier wieder gesehen. Ich sollte, ich sollte das Bild aus meinem Memetool raus machen.
Warum ist die Musik eigentlich so leise?
Ja Leute, also ich bin da echt zufrieden mit jetzt. Das war ziemlich easy, muss man sagen. Oder? War das nicht easy? Also schwierig war das jetzt nicht.
Was waren das für Weebsounds? Oh, ich habe noch viel bessere zu bieten.
Oder beste, das ist eigentlich der beste hier.
So, im Prinzip funktioniert das jetzt wirklich, ich weiß gar nicht, was ich sagen soll, ehrlich gesagt. Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich sagen soll, das hat jetzt viel einfacher und unproblematischer funktioniert, als ich mir das so vorgestellt habe.
Und ich meine, guckt es euch an, unoptimiertes Samba-Gestell hier, da kann man auch ein bisschen was machen. 655 Megabyte die Sekunde.
Also im Prinzip jetzt schon schneller als die SSD überhaupt packt. Und ich meine, ich hätte hier noch eine zweite SSD, aber da ist was drauf, was ich brauche. Sonst hätte ich mal eine SSD Rate 0 gemacht oder sowas jetzt. Über die Thunderboards hätten wir uns angucken können.
Aber brauchen wir nicht, weil wir haben es ja von der RAM-Disk ausprobiert. Wir haben es ja von der RAM-Disk ausprobiert und die RAM-Disk sagt, es ist haltbar 655 MB Schluss.
Ich bin auch verwirrt, warum es nicht schief läuft. PCI-SSD rein hängen ja an welchen Port denn? Ich habe doch nur noch einen einfach Port übrig. Den Rest haben wir ja vollgestopft gerade.
Und einfach Port reicht uns ja nicht. Angel Thumb. Oh Sebaro, nice.
Ja und jetzt zeige ich euch mal was. Nachdem das jetzt funktioniert hat, wie ich mir das nicht gedacht, wie ich mir das erhofft habe im Vorfeld, kann ich euch jetzt zeigen, was wir jetzt noch machen.
Dann stellen wir das Bild hier noch mal zusammen und schauen, was es abschließend denn kostet. Also die Netzwerkkarte, wie gesagt, die muss man auf eBay kaufen.
Ich mache es mal ein bisschen teuer. Die Netzwerkkarte kostet halt im Endeffekt was von 20 bis 60 ungefähr. Je nachdem, was man gerade für Angebote kriegt und wie lange man warten kann.
Die ganz Hardcore-Leute könnten sich noch einen, was aber mega sinnlos ist, sage ich gleich mal dazu, könnten sich noch einen Rate-Controller reinhauen, was halt Schwachsinn ist an einem PCI-Einfach-Einfach-Slot.
Es sei denn, man möchte quasi die zwei zusätzlichen Ports, die man damit maximal machen kann vom Speed her, mit einer ordentlichen Platte dran, halt besonders qualitativ hochwertig Attachen oder so.
Ich sehe keinen Sinn in einem Rate-Controller, beziehungsweise auch keinen Sinn in dem Bild für einen Hostbus Adapter, Rate-Controller, Dings. Also eigentlich nicht.
Zumal es ein Low-Build ist und die Dinger alle, ein Low-Power-Build ist und die Dinger alle ganz gut Strom verschlingen. Also ich glaube, da geht unter 10 Watt Idle, geht da gar nichts.
Aber mal so als Tipp, wenn ihr einen günstigen Rate-Controller sucht, und das muss, ich sage immer Rate-Controller, das ist eigentlich falsch.
Eigentlich verwenden die meisten Leute die Storage-Sachen-Bastel heute die Rate-Controller gar nicht mal als Rate-Controller, sondern einfach nur als Adapter, um die Platten anzuschließen.
Wenn du da sowas wie ZFS oder so drauf machst, da wird sogar explizit von abgeraten, dass man das mit einem Rate-Controller macht.
Dementsprechend wird der Rate-Controller einfach das Rate ausgeschaltet, beziehungsweise der Rate-Controller auf dummen HBA geflasht.
Wenn wir gerade beim Thema sind, wenn ihr einen günstigen HBA beziehungsweise einen günstigen Rate-Controller sucht, dann kauft euch den hier, den da könnt ihr euch kaufen.
Der kostet nämlich, der ist huge massive niedriger Preis. Wenn ihr da guckt, findet ihr den teilweise für 20 Euro.
Und der braucht so 10, 12, 13 Watt ein. G2A mache ich ja nicht mehr.
Aber wenn, dann hätte ich euch jetzt einen Refling schicken können.
Und was letzte Preis? Hä? Wie letzte Preis? Was letzte Preis, Alter?
Da steht eine Postleitzahl. Oh nein, schon wieder liegt. Wo steht sie? Wo ist sie diesmal?
Sie ist sie gar nicht. Sie ist sie nicht. Um rechts.
Ach da. Oh mein Gott. Nein. Schon wieder. Und bei Amazon. Wo bin ich bei Amazon jetzt?
Oh mein Gott. Diesmal bin ich in Hanau. Das letzte Mal war ich in Kahlstein.
Liegt. Das ist immer witzig. Wenn ich jetzt ein paar mal refresche, bin ich wieder woanders.
Nein, heute bin ich in Hanau. Eigentlich müsste ich in Meinkohl sein, aber... Ja, jetzt direkt so.
Also, so einen könnt ihr euch kaufen, wenn ihr einen Hostboss Adapter bzw. einen Rate Controller sucht.
Die Dinger sind günstig und taugen und ihr könnt die total simpel über... Nee, total simpel ist es nicht, aber relativ simpel flashen auf die Nicht-IBM-Firmware.
Es gibt tausende Anleitungen im Internet dazu. Und dann seid ihr den IBM Crap los und ihr könnt das Ding flashen zu einem dummen Hostboss Adapter
und könnt euch in euren Server knallen und ZFS oder so was mitmachen.
So, also wir schreien jetzt mal auf... Was haben wir denn? Also wir haben Netzteile, haben wir das drinne. Ok, passt. Brigabyte Case muss ich noch bestellen.
Netzwerk kostet ungefähr 20 bis 60 Euro. Ich habe hier gerade... Das muss man aber nicht machen.
Ich habe hier einen 8G-Riegel drin. Da reichen aber locker. Locker einen 4G-Riegel. Also irgendwie 25 Euro für den RAM.
Eine System-SSD habe ich jetzt eine genommen, die ich schon hatte. Man braucht... Also sagen wir so, es lohnt sich in dem Fall...
Der ursprüngliche Plan war ja, an den M2-Slot eine SSD dran zu machen für das System. Bis mir aufgefallen ist, dass ich gebated wurde und der PCI-Express nur einfach ist.
Musik. Ah. Das ist most... Da stand hier doch irgendwas von...
Two hours epic music. The power of music. Best of collection.
Hört jetzt eher so ein bisschen anehlemäßig an, aber... Jetzt ist wieder zu laut. Das finde ich bei den Playlists immer kacke, wenn die nicht wissen, wie laut...
Dass das eine leise ist und das andere so super laut. Wie switchen zwischen den Desktops hin und her? Mit Funktionstasten von meinem Keyboard.
Wie bekommst du den Vista-Locker hin? Ich glaube, hier habe ich gar nichts großartiges umgeschaltet. Und du switchst zwischen den Desktops. Offizielle Shortcut bei Windows ist Ctrl, Windows, Pfeil rechts, Pfeil links.
So, also das Bild. Aber ich bin echt überrascht, wie gut das funktioniert. Guckt euch mal, wir haben theoretisches... Das können wir jetzt ja gerade mal eintragen. Also wir kriegen getestet, haben wir 6,37G kriegen wir hin. Mit Samba kriegen wir ungefähr... Was haben wir hingekriegt mit Samba? 5,3G oder so.
Was ist dein Chrom-Logo? Das ist kein Chrom, das ist ein Chromium. Deswegen sieht das so komisch aus. Wann tut nochmal ein Video von dir kommen? Ich habe mir vorgenommen, ich mache dieses Jahr...
Neben Gaming mache ich vor allem, weil dazu kann ich halt eben ein bisschen was sagen, mache ich ein paar Technik-Videos. Also wie man zum Beispiel für 250 Euro sich einen 10 Gigabit Netzwerk daheim hinstellen kann.
Oder ein anderes Video, wie wir hier das Nass zusammengebaut haben oder sowas in der Richtung. Ok, also was haben wir? 5,3, das passt doch, 5,3 lassen wir mal stehen. Mikrotik-Tutorials, das ist glaube ich zu speziell für YouTube.
Ich will sowas allgemeines machen, wo jeder was von hat, der sich ein bisschen technisch interessiert. Zum Beispiel, die meisten Leute wollen eigentlich getrennte Netze von internem Netzwerk WLAN und ihrem komischen IoT-Kamera-Geräten.
Was wollen die? Das wissen die bloß nicht. Es haben so viele Leute ein Netz intern inklusive WLAN im gleichen Netz und haben dann dort drinnen noch ihre komischen China IoT-Geräte, die sonst was treiben oder Kameras oder sonst was.
Und das will man nicht und das wollen die auch nicht, aber die wissen nicht, dass sie das nicht wollen, weil sie keine Ahnung haben, was das für Auswirkungen hat. So sowas würde ich halt gerne Videos machen, wie man zum Beispiel dann das mal ordentlich trennt und das geht zum Teil sogar an der Fritzbox.
Das stimmt, Sebaro. Ein Video pro Tag, Never. Krieg ich nie hin, krieg ich nie hin. Ich bin Nasty und stinkt jetzt da. Moin.
Ja, heute sind die Namen aber wieder absolut huge. Achso, danke für die Follows. Ich gucke mal rein, wer am Start ist. Übrigens, Partnerdingsstellen habe ich gemacht, das müssen wir mal gucken, wann das soweit ist.
Also wer ist denn hier dabei? KST98, PSN, Myrtardella, die Hexe ist auch am Start, Dr. Bash, Technik Spielemann, Wolfi und X-Kombo Jam. Schön, dass ihr im Stream mit am Start seid und natürlich auch alle die so gucken und noch nicht gefollowed sind.
Das heißt, wenn ihr noch nicht gefollowed seid, bietet sich natürlich jetzt gerade an den Follow Knopf zu drücken, wenn euch der Stream gefallen hat. Wir machen jetzt ein bisschen Sellout.
Ihr könnt natürlich auch gerne bei mir auf Twitter und auf YouTube vorbeigucken, wenn ihr mehr sehen wollt in der Richtung.
Jetzt machen wir die Liste weiter. Ich habe meistens ein gutes Sellout Intro und ein ganz gutes Sellout Mitte. Wo ich noch Nachholbedarf habe, ist Sellout Outro. Das kriege ich noch nicht gut hin.
Hast du eine Idee, wie man ein Überwachungskamerasystem self-hosted hinbekommt? Die self-hosted Lösungen sind alle, naja, Schwachsinn, vergiss es, nein, die Open Source Lösungen sind alle, naja, aber ich habe da nicht so hohe Ansprüche.
Das Einfachste ist, einfach auf die Kamera zu gehen und zu gucken oder per VLC den Stream abzugreifen. Da kenne ich mich leider nicht aus.
Okay Leute, also, lassen wir überlegen, was haben wir denn hier? Das Netzteil haben wir drin, das Mainboard haben wir drin, das Case haben wir, das Netzwerk, RAM, 4G, System, SSD haben wir nicht.
Zusätzlich dazu braucht man jetzt noch den Adapter und da zeige ich euch gleich noch was, was ich jetzt noch vor habe. Circa 5-10 Euro für den M2 PCI Express Adapter.
Und jetzt gucken wir mal, weil, ich habe es euch ja vorhin gezeigt, als Case nehmen wir das hier und das passt wieder wie die Faust aufs Auge, also eigentlich richtig gut zusammen.
Das Case ist übelst billig mit irgendwie 70 Euro mit Hotspot-Rahmen schon drin, ja, das ist massiv billig.
Und das Coole ist, wir haben onboard, also aktuell habe ich nur die SSD dran gehabt, was ihr gesehen habt, aber man sieht hier, wir haben onboard 2.
Übrigens, wisst ihr was ich gerade sehe? Oder was ich mir gerade überlegt habe? Vielleicht können wir auch den Quad-Core nehmen, der ist nicht wirklich viel teurer.
Ich meine, man sieht es rein, für nass reicht der Dual-Core easy aus, aber wir könnten eigentlich auch das Quad-Core-Board nehmen, oder?
Warum habe ich denn nicht das Quad-Core-Board bestellt? Ah, ich habe das Quad-Core-Board nicht bestellt, weil ich nicht gecheckt habe, dass der PCI-Express-Steckplatz gar nicht 16-fach ist.
Man könnte aber ohne Probleme auch das Quad-Core-Board nehmen. Circa 70 Euro, weil das keine Unterschied, wahrscheinlich sollte man dann eher das Quad-Core-Board nehmen.
Oh, mein, Quad-Core, besser, Dual-Core, wenn es preislich keine Unterschiede nach. Gucken wir mal. Also, Geizhals-Stells, schauen wir mal. Geizhals.
Nein, das ist nicht das richtige Board. Alter, was ist mit der Musik los, ey? Das ist nicht das richtige Board. Jetzt ist die Musik wieder übelst laut. Diese Epic-Music-Compilation kann ich mir nicht entscheiden.
Das ist das falsche Board. Gigabyte 4. Ach, die haben das andere gar nicht gelistet, okay. Natürlich Fail. Also, das kostet 74. Schauen wir mal, was kostet das hier? Shopping.
Ach, gibt es das hier gar nicht zu kaufen? Okay. Ja, gut. Dann muss es das Dual-Core-Board sein. Ja.
Die haben das hier anscheinend nicht. Deutschland, das Board. Die Musik escalatet richtig. Ich weiß auch nicht, was da los ist. Aber jetzt müsste die Lautstärke halbwegs in Ordnung gehen, ne?
Aber tickenleiser. Ja, ich habe mal auf YouTube eine Mikrotik-Serie gesehen, die war ziemlich gut. Auf Deutsch. Das da, glaube ich. Ich glaube, die zwei Typen. Habe ich mal geguckt, das Tutorial. Das war ganz gut.
Warum gibt es denn das Quad-Core-Board? Warum gibt es das nicht in Deutschland? Das ist aber zackt. Huge. Huge sack. Na gut, dann müssen wir bei unserem Dual-Core-Board bleiben.
Keine Chance. Dann müssen wir bei unserem Dual-Core-Board bleiben. Und das kriegt man für, wie gesagt, um die 70 Euro. So in dem Dreh. Vielleicht erwischt man mal ein Angebot oder so.
Gut. Oh, ich habe Hunger, sage ich euch. Merci für Hunger. Ein Video über so eine Mikrotik-Box kann ich mal machen, dass die Leute übrigens auch mal einen ordentlichen Router gesehen haben, bzw. einen ordentlichen Switch gesehen haben.
Weil die meisten Leute kennen ja Fritzbox und sonst nix. Und es ist halt ein Unterschied, ob, kann ich euch ja nochmal zeigen. Wenn sich jetzt das hier zum Beispiel mal anguckt. Das ist jetzt hier quasi der Router, über den ich gerade ins Internet gehe.
Ich habe jetzt umgestellt von meiner PFSense-Box. Letztes Mal, wo ich gestreamt habe, war ich ja noch über PFSense online. Mittlerweile bin ich über den Mikrotik-Router online. Es ist gefühlt geschwindigkeitsmäßig überhaupt kein Unterschied.
Aber hier kannst du halt wirklich Gott und die Welt, du kannst alles einstellen. Du kannst alles wirklich einstellen. Du kannst mindestens das machen, was du im PFSense machen kannst, eher mehr. Dafür ist die Oberfläche nicht so schön wie PFSense.
Gründe für den Wechsel. Der hauptsächliche Grund war eigentlich, dass ich nicht mehr alles auf meiner 4HE-Kiste laufen lassen wollte.
Ich hatte ja einen dicken Xeon-Server mit 8 Kernen und ordentlich RAM und Gedöns und da lief halt alles aktuell drauf bei mir. Alles von der Heimautomatisierung bis Nextcloud bis Internet drüber. Alles. Wirklich alles. Komplett. Und das war mir einfach zu risikobehaftet irgendwie und hat auch zu viel Strom verbraucht.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, komm, für Internet machst du es relativ simpel. Kaufst dir einen Mikrotik-Router. Das Ding braucht 3,6 Watt, wenn es da rumsteht. Und kannst damit alles machen, was du im PFSense machst. Und du hast eine Sache weniger auf der fetten Kiste.
Beziehungsweise die Sachen ein bisschen besser aufgesplittet. Weil aktuell ist es halt so, aktuell kann ich noch nicht mal meinen fetten Server neu starten. Und dann gehen die Rollen nicht mal mehr richtig runter.
Also das ist schon ein Fail und deswegen wird das jetzt ein bisschen aufgesplittet. Das wird aufgesplittet in Mikrotik-Router für Netzwerkgedöns. Wird aufgesplittet in die Kiste, wo wir heute gebaut haben für Nextcloud und NAS-interne Geschichten. Und in ähnliches Board plus von SROC für Heimautomatisierungssachen.
Hast du dein Modem denn separat? Nein, dein Modem, das ist von Unity Media, ist das das mitgelieferte und für den Telekom Anschluss ist es die kleinste Fritzbox, die es gab.
Ist das. Also wirklich die billigste, die für irgendwie 70€ oder die ganz kleine Fritzbox. Die macht ja auch nichts, außer VDSL.
Was hältst du von Raspberry Pi Clustern für Heimautomatisierung? Nix, nichts. Raspberry Pi für Heimautomatisierung kann man machen, das ist zwar ein bisschen, also wenn man sowas wie Home Assistant drauf laufen lässt, ist es ein bisschen langsam.
Nicht wenn es erstmal läuft, aber wenn du config änderst und neu startest, das ist ultra nervig, da wartest du irgendwie 3 Minuten, deswegen das ging mir auf den Keks. Und ein Raspberry Pi Cluster ist, und vor allem ein Raspberry Pi Kubernetes Cluster, das ist cool zum Lernen, aber viel, viel zu komplex für eine Heimautomatisierungslösung.
Wozu? Der profitiert ja auch nix von. Wenn man, wenn man quasi ein Raspberry Pi Cluster zum Üben machen will, mit Lastverteilung, Auswahlsicherheit, wie du gesagt hast, vollkommen super, ja, aber für Heimautomatisierung dann da drauf laufen zu lassen, ist das zu komplex.
Heimautomatisierung sollte man so einfach wie möglich machen, dass es halt funktioniert. Also ich verstehe, was du meinst, wegen Auswahlsicherheit, klar, aber ich finde, nur für Heimautomatisierungszeug, wo du einfach einen Raspberry hinstellen könntest, der wahrscheinlich nie Probleme macht und im Zweifelsfall noch einen zweiten daneben mit einer kopierten SSD-Karte, das ist ausfallsicher genug und macht bestimmt weniger Probleme als ein Raspberry Pi Cluster.
Und gedönst zusätzlich dazu mitverwalten musst. Hast du doppeltes Nutt? Aktuell habe ich leider doppeltes Nutt, aber ich könnte doppeltes Nutt vermeiden, indem ich zwischen Fritzbox und meinem Mikrotik-Router halt ruhte und der Mikrotik-Router kein Nutt am externen Interface macht, das könnte ich machen.
Man würde nur noch die Fritzbox-Nutt machen.
KSC-890, da muss ich sagen, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
OpenSense bzw. PFSense, das ist zwar die beste Firewall-Diskribution, die es so gibt, finde ich, da kann auch links-linux-basiertes mithalten. Die Oberfläche ist halt eher für den versierten Heimanwender, der eben mehr Features will als so eine normale Fritzbox bietet.
Aber allein schon, wenn du dir anguckst, was es für ein Akt ist, eine OpenSense-Version zu updaten. Beim letzten Major-Update PFSense gingen die Hälfte der Konflikte der Leute nicht mehr und sowas.
Das ist halt... das willst du in deinem... das willst du eigentlich so nicht haben, wenn es nicht gerade daheim ist, wo du das verkraften kannst.
Deswegen wundert es mich nicht. Die Mikrotik-Dinger sind halt ein bisschen fummelig, weil das so viel kann, aber an sich sind die ziemlich gut.
Vor allem preis-leistungsmäßig sind die halt absolut... ja, ich benutze das Webinterface, frag mich nicht warum, weil... was du hast, das wichtigste ist, der Safe-Mode, den hast du auch im Webinterface.
Also der Safe-Mode hier ist... das ist auch sowas, was einer Fritzbox fehlt oder was glaube ich sogar auch PFSense teilweise fehlt. PFSense muss halt dann immer OK drücken. Aber so eine Sache, die man erst zu schätzen weiß...
Ich will das nicht safen... die man erst zu schätzen weiß, wenn man mal in der Situation war. Es gibt hier... ein Mechanismus in dieser Form hat jeder ernst zu nehmende Netzwerkhersteller.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Ubiquiti hat, aber ich gehe auch mal davon aus. Ich weiß es nicht. Wahrscheinlich haben die auch sowas. Ja, haben sie. Ja, haben sie. Bestimmt.
Safe-Mode heißt... also sprich, wenn ich jetzt hier Dinger ändere im Webinterface.
Mal angenommen, ich sag jetzt hier Interfacelist irgendwie... ich lösche jetzt mein Ladeninterface oder sowas.
Wobei, das löscht nicht wirklich das Laden, aber gehen wir mal von aus. Ich würde jetzt mein Ladeninterface löschen.
Das wäre ja ziemlich blöd, weil dann hätte ich mich ausgesperrt und ausgesperrt von seinem Netzwerkgerät ist das beschissenste, was dir passieren kann, wenn du nicht vor Ort bist.
Kann man sich ja irgendwie vorstellen, ne? Wenn du einen Router hast, irgendwo an der anderen Ende von Deutschland oder, sagen wir übertrieben, am anderen Ende der Welt.
Und du änderst Firewall-Regeln oder irgendwelche Configs oder Firmware-Updates oder was auch immer, ja?
Und es klappt fast nicht und du sperrst dich aus, ist ganz schön scheiße.
Da musst du da entweder hinfliegen, was noch mehr sagt, oder du musst lokal einen bezahlen, der das für dich resettet bzw. den Reset-Knopf etwas länger gedrückt hält, dass es Default-Settings hat.
Es ist komplett für'n Arsch. Also das will man nicht.
Deswegen hat jedes ernstzunehmende Netzwerkehersteller was wie den Safe-Mode.
Das heißt, wenn du den Safe-Mode anmachst und was änderst und dann deine Session abkackt oder deine Session keine Verbindung mehr hat oder sonst was in der Richtung, dann wird sie nicht gespeichert.
Dann ist spätestens beim Neustart wieder alles beim Alten.
Und du kannst auch bei den meisten Geräten den Timeout einstellen, so nach dem Motto, wenn nach 10 Minuten nichts passiert ist über die Verbindung, über diese Admin-Geschichte, über die Admin-Konsole, dann starte automatisch neu.
Das ist sehr praktisch. Hallo Brotholz. Warum mache ich nicht Holz Brot?
Dann ist das halt praktisch.
Clock X, das stimmt so. Du hast keine Konsole in Port.
Dafür ist das Zeug günstig.
Ich meine, guck mal, du kriegst den Einsteiger-Access-Point, kriegst du für 25 Euro. Und das, was du damit machen kannst, ist mega krass im Vergleich zu dem, was man mit einer Fritzbox machen kann routertechnisch.
Was genau ist denn an Winbox? Ich meine, ich habe natürlich Winbox auch schon mal auf gehabt und mir angeguckt.
Den größten Unterschied zum Webinterface habe ich jetzt nicht gesehen. Aber wahrscheinlich, weil ich es mir nicht lange genug angeguckt habe. Was ist dann zum Beispiel, was ist der große Unterschied zwischen, was macht für dich Winbox aus im Vergleich zum Webinterface?
Ja, ich wollte euch ja noch was sagen. Und zwar, worauf ich eigentlich raus wollte, ist, wir holen ja das Gehäuse hier. Und da sind vier Platten drin.
Achso. Ja, DevTag, das ist natürlich ein Argument. Stimmt. Ja, mehrere Tabs ist ganz praktisch. Aber hier dazu. Was haben wir eigentlich unter Raid-Systeme?
Das Wechselrahmen, im Wechselrahmen oder was? Aber worauf ich jetzt eigentlich die ganze Zeit raus wollte, wie gesagt, das hier ist ja das Mainboard. Und was man hier schön sieht, ist, wir hatten mal zweimal Onboardsata.
Da ist auch gerade einmal die SST dran. Und man hat hier den M2-Slot. Hier dazwischen hängt gerade so. Sollte ich mal ein Foto machen? Wie das ausschaut jetzt? Wobei, wie kriege ich das Foto dann in Strehm?
Ihr könnt es euch wahrscheinlich vorstellen. Hier ist quasi der M2-Slot drin. Das Ding steckt hier in dem Slot drin. Und da oben drauf ist die 10G-Netzwerkkarte.
Das einzige Problem an der 10G-Netzwerkkarte ist jetzt, man muss das Slotblech abmachen. Das Slotblech muss man abmachen. Und die Netzwerkkarte sitzt halt falsch rum. Normalerweise wäre der Ausgang von PCI-Geräten hier. Und die Netzwerkkarte endet halt hier.
Youtube-Video. Ich mache ein Youtube-Video, wenn das Bild läuft. Der Ausgang der Netzwerkkarte ist hier. So ungefähr über dem zweiten RAM-Slot. Allerdings ist es so, dass man, glaube ich, wenn man Glück hat, theoretisch noch einen RAM-Riegel reinbekommen würde.
Wenn man Glück hat. Es wird ganz eng an der Stelle. Da wird wirklich nicht viel Platz. Einfach ein paar E-Mails senden. Moment, ich mache da jetzt mal ein Bild von.
Guck mal auf das Bild.
Ich poste das Bild gleich auf Twitters.
Ich poste es mal kurz auf Twitter. Ich zeige es dir mal im Stream, wie das jetzt aussieht.
Das ist halt übelst Fail. Bilder-Share auch über Twitter.
Ich hoffe, man erkennt das.
So, ich habe es gepostet. Wartet mal. So sieht es aktuell aus.
Also sprich, hier steckt die 10G Netzwerkkarte drauf. Sie ist halt falsch rum, wie man sieht. Und sie hängt so über dem. Also ganz knapp. Da könnte ganz knapp einen RAM-Riegel reinpassen. Ganz knapp noch.
Das ist wirklich Millimeter. Hier sieht man den Adapter. Hier sieht man die 10G Karte drin. Und das ist das, worüber wir gerade auf dem Saal eingeloggt sind. Das hier ist Onboard, aber die Onboard verwenden wir ja gar nicht.
Und ein 8er RAM-Riegel. Hier müsste gerade noch ein weiterer RAM-Riegel reinpassen, wenn ich mir das so angucke. Ganz knapp. Vielleicht muss man unten von der Netzwerkkarte was abschneiden, dass es reinpasst. Aber an der Stelle ist auf der Netzwerkkarte ja nichts. Easy Netzwerkkarte sägen. Kein Problem.
Easy. Easy.
Ja. Und jetzt, um endlich mal zu sagen, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte die ganze Zeit. Ich krieg's ja irgendwie nicht gemacht. Dadurch, jetzt kann ich es wenigstens hier drauf zeigen. Ist doch viel besser.
Dadurch, dass wir die Netzwerkkarte jetzt hier drauf haben, haben wir diesen PCI-Express. Der sieht so nur aus, wie der Fake-16-Slot ist das hier unten. Ist der Einfach-Slot. Der aussieht wie ein 16er-16er-Slot. Haben wir noch den PCI-Express-Slot frei.
Und das richtig Neiße daran ist, wir haben ein Gehäuse, das Teppich liegt da, so wie vor drei Jahren schon. Wir haben ein Gehäuse, was vier Platten packt. Und da sieht man mal, wie gut das Bild irgendwie zusammenpasst.
Man hat zwei, man hat zwei On-Board, man hat zwei On-Board SATA Anschlüsse. Und ja, steht einfach hier unten drunter. Und jetzt könnten wir uns einfach noch einen billigen PCI-Express SATA Adapter kaufen.
Und schon können wir vier Platten anschließen mit voller Geschwindigkeit. Magnetplatten, SSDs nicht. Die Platten, die ich anschließe, diese zehn Terabyte Platten, die haben ein Maximum von lesen 250 MB.
Und jetzt kommt die Frage, wer aufgepasst hat, und warum ich mich so freue, wie gut das zusammenpasst. Wie viel MB die Sekunde schafft ein Einfach-PCI-Express 2.0-Slot? Wie viel schafft eine, eine, eine Lane? PCI, also ein Einfach. Ein Einfach angebundener, angebundener Extension-Card hier drin? 500! Richtig! Und was sind 250 x 2? 500! Und deswegen passt das so gut.
Also sprich, ich kann hier On-Board anschließen. Und das ist richtig, das ist richtig geil. Das ist richtig geil. Da sind es vier Platten. Ich habe 13 TB Platten.
Da könnte ich theoretisch meinen ZFS5-Rate einfach übernehmen. Und ich habe noch einen Platz für eine System-SSD. Oder wenn ich es ganz übertreibe für diese nice 4 TB SSD, die ich mir kaufen wollte. Die dreimal so viel kostet, wie das ganze System zusammen. Zweimal, zweimal so viel kostet.
Das ist doch echt geil, oder? Das ist echt nice. Wie viel schaffen gute HDDs dann maximal? 250 MB ist somit das schnellste, was ich bisher gesehen habe. Also bei diesen, bei 7200 Umdrehungen. In der Regel bist du ein bisschen schneller lesen als schreiben. Also sag mal so 250 lesen und so 220 schreiben oder so.
So in dem Dreh würde ich auch aktuell Festplatten sehen. Viel schneller wird es nicht sein. Wenn du schneller haben willst, musst du dir irgendwelche Enterprise, SAS, sonst was Platten kaufen.
Nee, die hat wirklich 250 MB die Sekunde. Kannst du gucken hier. Oder Benchmarks gucken. Das deckt sich auch mit dem. Das deckt sich auch mit meinen Erfahrungen mit den Platten. Ich habe die jetzt auch schon irgendwie zwei Jahre oder so.
Das kommt ungefähr hin. Haben die hier irgendwie einen Benchmark drinnen? Die Seite habe ich früher jeden Tag gelesen. Ich weiß nicht ob die noch aktiv sind so richtig. Hier unten Performance. Benchmark Performance.
Wie viel kosten die pro Terabyte? Können wir gleich mal schauen. Guck da. Ach und das ist sogar nur die langsame. Was packt die Ironwolf? Was heißt die Ironwolf eigentlich? 252, 236 packt die. Sequentiell natürlich nur.
Das ist auch so. Aber das ist auch so das Maximum was man aus Platten heute rauskriegt. Viel mehr geht nicht so bei den normalen erschwinglichen Platten.
Kannst du auch Eiskräuter. Du kannst ein Rate 0 über beliebig viele Platten machen. Man könnte mal ausrechnen ab wann das Rate nicht laut nichts also statistisch gesehen ist nicht möglich wäre mehr an Rate 0 zu erstellen.
Kann man ja ausrechnen. Man kann sich ausrechnen wie viel Fehler SSDs haben und wie hoch die Fail Quote ist von Platten und man sagt dann einfach einen erstellen von einem Rate dauert eine Minute.
Das heißt da könnte man ausrechnen was für einen Rate statistisch gesehen Rate 0 nicht mehr erstellbar wäre. Wie viele Platten man dazu bräuchte kann man ja ausrechnen. Es sind aber ein paar.
Eiskräuter ist es viel besser du kannst einfach nur 1 machen. Kannst du nur 1 machen aus 2 Platten. Da hast du dann zwar nur die halbe Größe aber die Lesegeschwindigkeit ist doppelt so schnell.
Schreibgeschwindigkeit ist einfach so schnell aber Lesegeschwindigkeit ist doppelt so schnell und die meiste Zeit wird im Heimumfeld von einem Nass eher gelesen als geschrieben.
Oder überleg doch mal was ihr auf dem Nass drauf liegen habt. Ihr schiebt da was drauf und dann wird es von mehreren Rechnern, mehreren Clients verwendet bzw. von euch mehrfach verwendet.
In der Regel schreibst du da weniger drauf als du liest. 50 SSDs werden 0 easy. Dazu fällt mir nur ein 50 SSDs. Das ist gar kein Problem.
So, genau. Wir kaufen jetzt nämlich ein. Wir gucken jetzt mal was es für einen sata, für einen billigen sata Controller gibt. Einfach. PC express einfach.
Kann auch meinetwegen ein Vierfach Controller sein. Der kriegt halt dann nur einfach Speed. Ist im Prinzip ziemlich egal.
Und dann haben wir, dann ist das Bild ultra nice. Dann ist das finde ich, wie gesagt bevor ich ein Video zu machen möchte, dann ist das wirklich das beste Low Budget Nass Bild was man sich so holen kann.
Das ist so nice. Vier Platten. Vier Platten. Idle. Hier Leute ich gucke jetzt mal drauf. Idle. Das hat, Idle aktuell braucht es 9,2 Watt und jetzt passt mal auf.
Ich zeige euch noch mal was. Es geht Schlag auf Schlag auf. Bam, ba ba bam. Wir installieren jetzt mal Power Top und machen ein paar Stromsparoptimierungen ein.
Wir machen ein paar Stromsparoptimierungen ein und gucken mal ob, ist alles bad, alles, alles sucked. So. Speichern. Jetzt haben wir Strom, Stromkram optimiert.
Und jetzt gucke ich mal drauf und jetzt brauche ich genau 7,9 Watt Idle. Das ist ultra nice. Das ist ultra nice. Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, was da gerade läuft.
Das ist die System-SSD und eine 10 Gigabit Netzwerkkarte. 7,9 Watt Idle. Das ist super wenig. Überlegt euch mal. Das wird auch nicht viel mehr.
Wenn ihr da jetzt Platten dran hängt, die Platten sleepen eh zum größten Teil, dann ändert sich da nicht viel dran.
Und sagen wir mal so, wenn die Platten laufen und benutzt werden, dann kommen da nochmal so 20 Watt obendrauf.
Allerdings nur wenn die Platten auch verwendet werden. Und es ist ja keiner gezwungen da 13 T-Platten rein zu machen.
Kannst du einfach eine SSD rein hängen, dann bleibt es immer auf dem Dreh. Soll ich mal, soll ich mal volle Pulle, soll ich mal den Rechner auslasten und gucken wie warmer wird und wie,
wie viel Strom man braucht. Wollen wir mal machen. Achso ja, Sensors sollten wir erst mal installieren.
Also unten im Fenster seht ihr jetzt wie warm das ganze Ding ist nachdem der Kram fertig installiert ist. Watch Sensors.
Also 2 Kerne, 2 Kerne, 34 Grad. Das Ding ist passiv gekühlt. Behalte das im Hinterkopf, ist passiv gekühlt. Also das kann durchaus jetzt ziemlich hot werden.
Wenn auch kein hotes Grill, aber es kann ziemlich hot werden. So, dann nehmen wir mal den allseits beliebten Prime 95. Gibt es nämlich auch für Linux?
Mal gucken. Vielleicht ist es ja sogar bei Ubuntu dabei. Nein, Ubuntu hat kein Prime 95 dabei. Gut, dann laden wir es uns von der Seite runter.
Denke mal das hier. So, Clocks HD. Ich habe das gleiche auf meiner 8 Kern Xeon Kiste gemacht. Der braucht dann, also wenn alle 8 Kern arbeiten,
haben wir 450 Watt oder so. Das Ding frisst, ey, ist der Wahnsinn. Aber es eilt meistens bei ein bisschen unter 100 Watt rum.
Trotzdem, trotzdem viel, viel mehr als das neue Zeug, was ich jetzt zusammen bastle hier. Okay, Prime 95.
Okay, Prime 95, wo haben wir es? Da. Mprime, Mprime. Bäm, starten. Join GIMP, nein. Sind GIMP genug, wir müssen GIMP nicht joinen.
Number of Torture Test Thread 2. Type of Torture Test to run. Small. Maximum Heat. Bäm. Accept. Yes. Der Lukas Lemer ist am Start.
Okay, jetzt wird es warm. Jetzt wird es warm, gehe ich mal von aus. Was ist die neue Hardware? Das da. Switch mal kurz rüber.
Die neue Hardware ist das da. Das ist ein Low Power Board mit Embedded CPU und da haben wir eine 10 Gigabit Netzwerkarte draufgefuddelt.
Und haben festgestellt, wir kriegen ungefähr 6,37 Gigabit durch. Patrick, wie läuft es? Es funktioniert alles viel besser als ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
So, also wir brauchen jetzt gerade 15 Watt. Also sprich volle Pulle und auf Vollleistung braucht der Rechner auch noch 15 Watt.
Das ist wirklich nichts. Ist es das Board, was du Silvester rausgesucht hast? Wird das Silvester raus, Vorsilvester? Äh, ne, ist es nicht.
Das ist jetzt das hier. Das ist das hier. Da, das da ist es. Das hat nur einen Dual Core, aber es hat einen M2-Slot. Den brauchen wir, den M2-Slot.
Roffelmann, der Roffelmann ist der beste Silvester hier. Aber guck mal, es hält sich doch in Grenzen. Wirklich, wirklich warm wird das nicht.
Ok, ich denke mal, wenn wir das jetzt ein bisschen laufen lassen, wird es noch wärmer. Und wenn das mal in einem Gehäuse drin ist, wird es noch ein bisschen wärmer.
Aber keine Ahnung, wie viel, wie warm der, wie warm der werden darf. Wahrscheinlich auch 105 Grad. Ne hier, ab 95 Grad ist kritisch. Da sind wir noch ganze Ecke von entfernt.
Und der wird ja auch nie über Stunden, kommt ja noch dazu, der wird ja auch nie über Stunden 100 Prozent ausgelastet sein.
Das ist ja kein Sauber im Heimbereich. Ja, aber ihr seht, das Ding ist halt voll. Alle beiden Kerne.
Massive. Ja, vorher tackte der sich runter. Genau, ne, ne, Shutdown tut er ganz bestimmt nicht.
Als Bridge zwischen Fernseh und Router.
Also, wenn du keine Bedenken hättest, den Fernseh direkt an den Router zu stöpseln, dann musst du auch keine Bedenken haben, das mit WLAN Bridge direkt dran zu stöpseln.
Terminal, das ist genau um Terminal. Was hältst du von QNAP? Die sind nicht schlecht, genauso wie die Synology-Dinger, die sind auch nicht so übel.
Aber ich mag halt lieber, wenn ich das alles selbst machen kann. Also auch betriebssystemmäßig.
Wobei man sagen muss, die Synology-Dinger, diese Synology gibt es ja sogar in so einem Open Source, ne nicht Open Source, sondern so einen komischen Fork von dem man sich selbst installieren kann.
Die sind schon, die sind schon ganz cool. Aber sie sind halt relativ teuer. Und du kriegst halt nicht exakt das, was du haben willst.
Ist halt, also ich würde mir keins kaufen. Xpenology, oder Xpenology, genau das meine ich. Moin, Xperic.
Also wau, solange du ein ordentliches WLAN-Passport hast, würde ich mir da keine Gedanken zu machen.
Du kannst ja ein bisschen mit der Firewall rumspielen in dem Mikrotik-Ding, ja. Du kannst ja da auch Sachen blocken, wenn du auf Nummer sicher gehen willst.
Wenn du auf Nummer sicher gehen willst, dann blockst du halt einfach alles außer das von der Fernseh-IP.
Also guck mal, das wird nicht wirklich warm, das Ding. So und Verbrauch haben wir jetzt 15,2 Watt. Das ist wirklich nix.
Das ist nix.
Also ich bin echt begeistert. Ich bin echt begeistert. Massive.
So und jetzt schauen wir mal, was es denn für billige SATA-Controller so gibt.
Und zwar, wir gucken nicht einfach, wir nehmen nicht irgendeinen random SATA-Controller.
Wir nehmen den gleichen SATA-Controller, wie der Hersteller auf seinen Mainboards verbaut.
Das ist zwar nicht zu vergleichen mit einem ordentlichen Ausbruchsadapter, aber es ist ja auch ein Low-Energy, ein Low-Power, Low-Budget-Bild.
Also sprich, wenn für zwei Platten der Onboard-Controller bzw. der bei den eingebauten SATA-Controller bei SROC ausreicht,
dann können wir uns den gleichen Controller auch so kaufen. Und zwar, was baut ein SROC ein?
Weil das ist ja das andere Board, was ich geholt habe, da jetzt mit 4. So und die haben in einem ASS, in irgendeinem Media, Media, genau.
Das ist der SATA-Controller, den die verwenden. Und da hätten wir auch keine Schmerzen, unsere Platten anzuschließen.
Deswegen können wir uns auch einfach eine PCI-Express-Variante davon kaufen.
Besagenhafte 699 bei eBay kommt bestimmt aus China.
Ich werde mit euch, dass es aus China kommt. Das ist bestimmt China Shop.
Wie viel Watt wird das dann ziehen? Was, was, was ist das?
Das ist China. China, ja. Auch Shenzhen. Alles kommt aus Shenzhen, ey.
Wenn die Festplatten mit Volllast arbeiten, das kommt auf die Festplatten an.
Also Festplattenverbrauch ist ganz unterschiedlich.
Wenn du da jetzt irgendwie so eine WD-Green oder so dran stöpselst, macht die einfach, keine Ahnung, wenn du das vergleichst,
nimmst du irgendwie so eine WD-Green im Vergleich zu irgendwie so 7200 Umdrehungen Seagate, dann braucht die einen Viertel oder so davon.
Also es kommt wirklich ganz entscheidend auf die Festplatten an.
Aber sag mal mal so, wenn du von dicken 10TB, 7200 Umdrehungen nicht irgendwie Stromspar, sonst was HDDs ausgehst,
denke ich mal kannst du so, ich weiß nicht, 5, 6 Watt oder so pro Festplatte draufrechnen.
Das ist ungefähr, wenn du erst das DS nimmst, faktisch gar nichts zusätzlich.
Und so ansonsten pro Platte irgendwie 5, 6 Watt.
Wobei die Platte halt zum größten Teil eh sleept und dann nix braucht und dann nahezu nix.
Und wenn du irgendwie WD-Green oder so nimmst, die brauchen halt weniger.
Ok, was haben wir denn hier, erst Media, das ist zu teuer, das sprengt das Budget 28 Euro.
Ich brauch irgendwas billiges.
5 Euro Data Controller.
Teuer, alles zu teuer.
Schnittstellenkarten, Storage Controller, Schnittstellenkarten.
4,92 Euro, was geht mit denen ab?
Da lohnt sich ja fast aus EU zu bestellen.
Das ist echt billig.
Amazon UK, das lohnt sich ja sogar Amazon UK zu bestellen.
Da hast du Versand.
Was kostet denn der Versand Amazon UK nach Deutschland?
Was wird gemacht? Ich such gerade einen billigen SATA Controller.
3 mit Prime? Ja, aber ich hab ja kein Prime in England.
Oder ist Prime übergreifend?
Ah, jebaited.
Jebaited, das gibt's überhaupt nicht.
Huge jebait.
Das gibt's überhaupt nicht.
Was soll das denn? Warum ist das hier so billig gelistet und dann gibt's das nicht?
Was soll das?
Das ist huge jebait.
Das ist mir zu teuer.
Schnittstellenkarten, Storage Controller, Schnittstellenkarten.
Wir gucken jetzt einfach mal Verbindungstechnik SATA.
Okay, das billigste ist tatsächlich dieses Ding.
Wobei es mir egal ist, das ist der passende Controller.
Der hat sogar vier, der hätte sogar vier Anschlüsse.
Was halt fail ist, weil vier mal über SATA einfach geht überhaupt nicht.
Wir gehen auf AliExpress.
Alter, wir gucken wieder, was es auf AliExpress kostet.
Der hatte eine massive gute Bewertung hier.
So, und was haben wir hier? Schnittstelle SATA, ab, einfach, äh, ja.
Anscheinend müssen wir dann doch irgendwie so einen komischen Controller hier kaufen.
UK noch dabei, bam. Okay, und warum ist das auf einmal in UK jetzt nicht mal gelistet?
SATA, SATA, ab eins, SATA.
Nein, Beliebtheit ist das, wir wollen am besten Preis sortieren.
2,45 Euro, F, was ist das? PCI, es wird ja immer schlimmer.
PCI, nee, PCI in 2K19, also PCI holen wir garantiert nicht.
Einmal seriell und einmal, Leute, ich hab gesagt, ich will SATA haben.
Ich hab schon gesagt, ich will SATA haben, oder? SATA? SATA?
SATA? SATA? Jetzt, ha? Ah, jetzt.
Okay, gucken wir mal, was das bei, ach, was juckt's mich, AliExpress.
AliExpress ist es mal wieder richtig billig, ne? AliExpress kostet einfach 8 Dollar.
Warte, wir stellen uns mal um auf Euro.
7,65 Euro, und der Versand aus China kostet wieder 80 Cent oder sowas?
Okay, sorry, 85 Cent der Versand aus China, ja. AliExpress Standard, 1,22.
Also wir würden bei AliExpress die Hälfte sparen.
Also wer wirklich der Sparfuchs vor dem Herrn ist, der kann dann bei AliExpress bestellen.
Obbei ich denen halt nichts glaube, ne? Die sagen zwar, dass es dieser Chip ist,
aber ob das wirklich dieser Chip ist, so.
Ja, das ist bei AliExpress so. 21 bis 40 Tage Lieferzeit.
Das kommt halt auch, kommt halt aus China.
Wenn du Glück hast, kannst du aus Russland liefern lassen,
aber die meisten liefern nicht aus Russland nach Deutschland.
Lieferzeit, aber das ist normal. AliExpress Lieferzeit.
Alles andere lohnt sich nicht, du kannst ja natürlich den 8 Euro Data Controller
in 20 Tagen für 41 Euro schicken lassen.
Wenn die eine EU-Lage hätten, das steht immer hier oben.
Das steht auch immer hier oben, ob China, Russia oder sonst was, und da steht nichts.
Was auf Tiny Deals? Ach, das ist irgendeine andere China-Seite.
Es gibt so viele China-Seite, ich kaufe das eh nicht aus China.
Wie das für 8 Euro geht, das geht für 8 Euro, wenn du deine Leute so fertig machst,
dass sie lieber vom Dach springen, anstatt für dich weiter Dinger zu produzieren.
Deswegen kaufen wir da nichts.
Dass ich da nicht schon eigentlich viel mehr Dinger als nötig gekauft habe,
aber das kaufen wir da nicht.
Oh, was? Google Shop? Oh, Guada? Ach, eBay.
eBay kommt bestimmt auch aus China. Seven Shops, irgendwas kommt bestimmt aus China.
Wobei, haben wir da nicht eben schon geguckt? Ja, Shenzhen, haben wir eben schon geguckt.
eBay, eBay, eBay, eBay, eBay, eBay, das hört überhaupt nicht mehr auf. Alles über eBay.
Okay, das günstigste über Amazon war ja irgendwie das da.
Irgendwie so war es hier, 14,85 Euro. Das günstigste über...
hallo suchen suchen das ist das jebait das ist überhaupt nicht dieser chip was
was machte amazon warum zeigt mir amazon diese karte an wenn ich danach suche
und es ist gar nicht dieser controller sondern in den j mikron irgendwas
gebet nicht nur geis hails und und gigabyte mich sondern amazon auch noch
jebait ganz so schlimm ist er noch nicht
ist es so teuer hier da müssen wir mal gucken also ein sata controller kommt da
auf jeden fall noch rein und mir geht es voll auf den keks dass ist diese diese
vier euro das ist diese vier euro angebot nicht gab auf
in uk mit stellen karten
rocco der rocco 1a das ist das ist das ist china das ist china angebot
wo ist der rocco 1 0 7 7 4 3 amazon die
das ist gar nicht so übel
das ist die china karte liefert die der hier verkauft ja das kommt auch aus china guck mal
lieferzeit 24 jahr bis bis 2 februar das ist und das braucht alles so lang da kann
es auch direkt aus china bestellen
also wenn man geld sparen möchte kauft man sich also die billig china variante ich werde
mir wahrscheinlich irgendwie so eine keine ahnung irgend so ein 15 euro ding halt kaufen kann man
kann man hier eigentlich suchen not ebay hier das not ebay
ok also müssen hier müssen wir wahrscheinlich irgendwas um 18 euro ausgeben das ist doch das
ist doch exakt die gleiche karte oder aber exakt die gleiche karte das ist doch wirklich
eins zu eins bloß ein schlechteres foto das ist doch eins zu eins die gleiche karte bloß
das ist foto bei bei dem china shop sagt lt 107 lt 11 das ist die gleiche karte oder minus zeit
also es sieht so aus als müssten wir irgendwie so mit 15 bis 20 euro rechnen für den sata
controller sagen wir mal es hier 18 euro und also sind wir so bei sie hatte das hatte
irgendwie auch 40 oder so gekostet nee ich ja ungefähr 40 zusammen das kostet irgendwie
70 auch paar euro mehr also sind wir jetzt bei was sind wir was haben wir denn hier insgesamt 180
das war das mal aus 80 war mal 210 105 100 200 15 quickmaps und 235 und das noch obendrauf
30 sagen wir mal die hälfte von 260 und dann noch eine ssd 20 25 ja wir sind so bei 280 euro
würde ich sagen das ist visual studio code weil das das verwenden die coolen leute heute die
weniger coolen leute die verwenden immer noch wippen auch guck mal der rechner ist mittlerweile
ordentlich warm geworden der ist jetzt schon bei 60 grad also so über den daumen gepeilt
würde ich mal sagen 280 euro für 280 euro was du da an performance kriegst was du was du da im
endeffekt an an gesamtpaket kriegst ich kenne kein anderes bild an handwerks zusammenstellung was
da in die nähe kommt und schon gar nichts fertiges gar kein fertiges nass ich meine klar das ist
kein enterprise business sonst was ding was ich irgendwo hinstellen würde wenn da 100 leute mit
arbeiten garantiert nicht aber für daheim ist das vollkommen ok und wenn man sagt man macht
da sogar zfs drauf dann kann man sich überlegen ob man nicht vielleicht ein 8 g ram riegel nimmt
der kostet nicht so viel mehr der kostet dann irgendwie 35 euro oder irgendwie 40 euro oder
sowas oder es geht auch mit 4 g ja wie gesagt wenn man damit wenig leute drauf zugreift dass
man dafür irgendwie terabyte weise ram braucht ist so mysterium so wichtig wenn du halt viel
cashen willst was zfs gerne macht md endung ist einfach nur dass es markdown ist dass du
format markdown heißt du kannst das formatieren relativ simpel gucken die rechte seite ist die
formatierte das links ist der quelltext quasi rechts die formatierte aber das das nass bild
ist wirklich ultra nice dass da bin ich echt zufrieden mit dass das so funktioniert hat wenn
das budget ist gut 280 euro die performance ist super nice in der preiskategorie in der
preiskategorie quasi 6,37 g ist top es ist komplett silent bis auf die platten da ist
nicht ein lüfter drin das bord ist das bord ist passiv gekühlt die 10 g karte ist passiv
gekühlt es eskaliert die musik wieder das ist ja es passt passt halt zum nass bild ja und die
ssd ist weder passiv noch aktiv gekühlt ist gar nicht gekühlt ist einfach im rahmen drin was
bedeutet dass das ein komplett silent bild ist mit massig performance mehr als ausreichend für
alles was man daheim irgendwie machen will es ist billig und um die ganze sache noch mal zu
toppen es verbraucht im endeffekt so gut wie nix an strom doch richtig nice oder bin begeistert
bin richtig begeistert
und dazu kommt was mir gerade noch einfällt was mir gerade noch einfällt du kannst an ganz
vielen ecken und enden sparen bei dem bild weil wir haben ein netzteil genommen was du mit einem
normalen mit so einem stecker netzteil betreibst also sprich wenn einer einen 12 volt netzteil
da hat was also jetzt nicht so dieses standard 12 volt 05 ampere netzteil wenn einmal einer
ein 12 volt netzteil da hat was die nötige den nötigen wums bringt um das bord betreiben
zu können kann er das verwenden er kann ram verwenden ddr4 ram es ist nämlich ein ganz
normales ddr4 kommt hier rein hier nicht da da ganz normales ddr4 dass er kann ram verwenden
den er noch hat er kann platten und ssd verwenden die er schon hat ja und wenn er gerne usb stick
dran machen möchte um system zu installieren und es nicht per ssd machen will kann er das
auch verwenden so perfekt success würde ich sagen was ist denn da schon wieder für rumgelacke
im chat am start kannst du den bild noch mal wo hochleiten ja mache ich ich mache eine
geilzahls eine geilzahls liste das einzige was ich nicht in die geilzahls liste packen
kann ist die netzwerkarte weil die netzwerkarte muss man gucken wo man wo man 10g karten kriegt
die kriegt man gebraucht also günstig kriegt man die nur gebraucht alles andere kannst
hier neu kaufen und irgendjemand hat gefragt ob man nicht auch noch rgb rgb beleuchtung
machen kann wir haben ja quasi noch 20 euro oder wenn man wenn man die sachen super billig
bekommt 30 euro budget davon kann man sogar noch rgb beleuchtung machen wenn man ganz
ganz scharf drauf ist hat erstmal mal 300 euro oder aber was ich eher empfehle ist macht
8 gigabyte ram anstatt rgb rein das ist auf jeden fall die bessere idee wie lange bin
ich schon an drei stunden jetzt genau auf die sekunde fast pock ja fertig oder wie warm
wird die kiste 60 grad über 60 grad kommt hier nicht raus auch wenn der lukas lemer
hier richtig am abgehen ist 15 watt 15,1 15,1 watt bm jetzt schreckt in your face nice sehr
nice ist bild oder ist ich bin ihr merkt vielleicht ich bin wirklich begeistert ich
bin wirklich zufrieden mit der ganzen geschichte vor allem dass das mit dem mit der 10g karte
so gut funktioniert hat zeigt mir irgendetwas was günstiger ist und das bietet silent ist
und also das geht wird man nicht finden und immer halt disclaimer unten dran wie gesagt
irgendwo in in der enterprise büro umgeben würde ich nicht unbedingt stellen da hast
du wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal so sehr wegen der zuverlässigkeit sondern eher weil es
bisschen wenig leistung dafür haben sollte aber für die familie daheim reicht das mehr
als aus günstige rgb led stripes auf aliexpress tut euch keinen zwang an natürlich silent
ohne die platten also ich habe es noch nicht geschafft die platten quasi trotz umdrehung
silent zu kriegen und man kann man kann natürlich auch sagen hey ich mach da nur ssd rein man
kriegt immerhin 6,3 geht rüber achso wir wollten ja gucken wir wollten ja gucken was wieviel
gigabyte pro euro das sind also ich zeige euch mal welche platte ich habe ich finde
die sie geht platten gehen eigentlich die klappern halt beim zugriff ganz schön aber
ich habe das ja auch in dem jebait heute wir werden heute an vielen stellen jebait hat
habe ich das gefühl pc lustig alles mögliche hauptsächlich also hauptsächlich verwende
ich an mein das für gameplay videos youtube und sowas normalerweise mache ich das so ich
speichere gameplays auf einer intern festplatte und die die dann was taugen die schiebe ich
auf das dass die platte wieder ein bisschen platz kriegt backups natürlich das sind so
die hauptsächlich hauptsächlich backups bei mir hauptsächlich backups ja und zumal
ich mein das halt nicht nur das verwende sondern den speicher drin wie gesagt auch für den
nextcloud und sowas ja wir wollten gucken sie geht ein wohl ich finde so geil dass es
die dinger mittlerweile mit zehn mit 14 terabyte schon gibt was da us muss ich drauf läuft
aktuell läuft der ubuntu server drauf aber du kannst da im prinzip drauf laufen lassen
was du willst also kostet kostet pro wo sieht man dann was die pro gigabyte kostet
steht doch da irgendwo das habe ich doch hier schon mal gesehen da muss man wahrscheinlich
die übersicht ja preis pro terabyte 10 10 10 10 10 10 10 5 5 5 mal 10 hat 5 mal 10 was
ist das für eine beknackte kapazität bis ab 10 ab 10 die da genau kostet 29 euro pro
terabyte ab 48 die wegmaps ja wir können einfach mal alternet gucken die haben da ich rechne
das doch jetzt nicht selbst aus auch wenn man das nur noch teilen müsste sich tausend
aber dann das ist mir zu zu low skill ich ja ich lasse seiten rechnen für mich sata
drei kräufe so da ist es auch hier die gucken wir mal was die günstigste günstigste zur
zeit ist an platte die günstigste platte zur zeit sind vier terabyte von sie geht für
23 73 pro terabyte ok und was hat das andere kostet noch mal 28 ja ok es sind nicht sind
nicht sind nicht super günstig oder so aber es geht iron wolf sechste guck mal die günstigste
zehner ist von nein geht es bei alternet ist es einfach teuer also die günstigste günstigste
platte gibt es anscheinend gerade 16 moment was nein nein ich habe mich verguckt 16 tb
bundle hier 29 29 pro terabyte kostet die da hat aber einer schön gerechnet oder wenn
es die ab 298,98 die schwachsinn ich bin ein noob das da ergibt sich aus dem preis easy
quickmaps im kopf bei rabo networks was auch immer für den shop sein soll nicht was von
gehört ok also der rechner wird nicht heißer als 61 ich habe es heute nicht mit einheiten
wird es wird nicht wärmer als 61 g also 16 62 gigabyte easy temperatur man darf sich
einfach abbrechen anscheinend warum nicht quitt sondern exit 5 ja auch zu angenehm die bedienung
sonst ja wenn ich das eine weile im betrieb habe dann mache ich auch ein video zu da 10
g dass das ich bin wirklich sehr sehr begeistert so er wird so irgendwie einen günstigen deal
finden für einen günstigen deal für einen sata controller finden irgendwas was halt
nicht aus china kommt und fit star braucht aus china aus schweiz aus schweiz aber lieferung
23 januar von wegen kommt das aus der schweiz wird partnerschaft jetzt muss ich abwarten
also ich habe mich darum gekümmert ich habe zumindest schon mal counts verknüpft und
alles soweit in die wege geleitet aber noch angenommen ist noch nichts also das kommt
alles aus china der regler regler rate das klingt nach einer guten marke irgendwie passt
gut zusammen haben sie für eine karte regler rate alles kommt einfach aus china china china
china hongkong schien was ja im prinzip china ist ja ok gut weil ich gehe jetzt was essen
ich hoffe euch hat der streben gefallen schenzen ja alles aus schenzen ich hoffe euch hat der
streben gefallen und aber schluss bis denn macht es gut zu bis morgen morgen wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen früher gibt es was zum hosten aus der inno guck mal ob ich was hausen kann
von denen die die ich follower kann das er das irgendwie kaum einer online ist gerade
bob ross nein bob ross müssen wir nähe ist keiner an
switch grill nähe
einer der farbjahnen streben an das dann macht's gut bis morgen wie gesagt ein bisschen früher
ich